- Let me, may be a second.
Let me just. (screams)
(screams)
- Now I'm scared.
- I feel like a dragon bull fan now.
- Yeah, I'm ready to talk about that one.
- No, you haven't done your steroids yet.
- Oh.
- What's up simps?
Welcome back to another
episode of Trash Taste.
I'm in, simp lord number one.
And I'm with simp lord
number two and three.
We're tired, have you guessed?
(all laugh)
I hope I hope Mudan left that
fucking shouting thing in
at the beginning.
Cause that is like, that's not an act.
We sometimes do that
just to wake ourselves up
for the show.
- Yeah, I'm taking a
page from corners book.
I was about to say taking
a book from Connor's page.
Wait a minute.
That doesn't sound right.
- So what have you guys
been up to this week?
I know Connor you went on a trip, right?
- I did, but before that.
I got this sick new shirt.
- Where'd you get that sick shirt?
- Probably the same place
you got your sick shirt.
- And Joey got his.
- What? when was this?
Yeah, that's right.
We're finally releasing merch.
After all this time.
We've seen it on the subreddit,
we've seen it on the Twitter
and we're like, where's the merch guys?
where's the merch? cash in on that merch,
you know, be a modern YouTuber.
We finally got our own Trash
Taste T-shirts in white
and in black.
- Yes.
So yeah, if you want to
Simplus you can go to...
Where's the store again?
- Yeah, so this is a special
deal that we're doing right now
with our friend, Bakuretsu,
who, if you guys can see the logo,
he's the guy who designed the logo.
And he decided to, this is
official collaboration merch
for a limited time, only two weeks.
So you have until I believe
October 24th, 12:00 PM
Eastern time to pre-order these shirts.
And hopefully by the time,
around Christmas time maybe,
you guys will be able to get these shirts.
You can get it in either white or black.
- So buy them, buy them now.
- Yes, go buy them now.
- This is more like, kind of
like an experiment for us.
We always talking about merch.
So we didn't know how many
of you would be interested.
This is just like a first release.
So, if you like this then
we might do more merch
in the future, who knows?
- It's a very simple design,
but we just wanted to start simple.
- Yeah, just start simple,
you know, easy to know.
- Materials are amazing,
I got to say boys.
- Oh yeah, this is much better quality
than what you'll get at
regular T-shirt sites.
But so, if you're interested in that
go to bakuretsu.co/trashtaste
link's in the description as well.
And yeah, hopefully you
guys will simp for us
with these beautiful new shirts.
- But yes, Joey, I did go on a trip.
- Where'd you go?
- I went to Niigata,
which is Northern North.
- Yeah, it's like directly
North of Japan, not Japan.
Directly, North of Tokyo is
what I was trying to say, yeah.
- I had a friend, Kenta, from university.
Who actually loved the story
parts from our university.
Cause he was like correcting
some of the details to me
- Oh, really
- in my mind.
Yeah, yeah.
And how like the Neo Nazi
guy made like phosphorus
chemical substance (Garnt
laughing) in the building.
- Were your fucking
roommates like Walter White
or something?
- Honestly, this guy was insane, man.
But anyway.
Yeah.
It was nice meeting him again.
I haven't seen him in ages
and he lives in Northern Japan
and he's a teacher there and a pastor.
And yeah, he's chill.
Just went up to see him.
- A pastor?
- Pastor, yeah. He's a pastor.
So in japan...
- Like P-A-S-T-O-R not P-A-S-T-A.
- NOT pasta.
- He's a pasta, linguine.
- I can't say it right, a pastor.
It's a pasta.
If I want to eat pasta, I would have that,
but he's a pastor.
(Garnt laughs)
- Did you eat pasta with the pastor?
- I did, yeah, I did that.
Yeah, because in Japan there's a...
This is kind of so damn and condescending.
There's a job for like foreigners.
He doesn't even look that foreign.
He still looks Japanese.
He's half, like we.
- All right.
- He's, half Wales, half Japanese.
And his job is to
basically repeat a script
that a real pastor might.
Like it's all for show.
So they just want a foreign looking guy
to like say the words.
- So he's not even like a legit pastor?
- No, none of them are.
(Joey laughs)
- It's like a fake service.
So you pay a guy and
he just says the lines
and does all the moves
and looks (Garnt laughs)
the real part.
Feel like he's seen a
pastor, like that's his job.
He marries people
- Wait, wait, how is that a job?
In what job sector is it needed?
- I think there's a huge market in Japan
for wanting a foreign experience wedding.
It's like a really like.
- Could I find this on Craigslist?
like looking for fake pastor.
- No, it's interesting,
it's expensive as well.
He was telling me the price, it's premium.
It's for like rich people.
- Rich and dumb people.
- Yeah, to us that's dumb as fuck,
but to them it makes sense.
So that's his job and yeah,
he was basically like,
you want to hang out in
Niigata and I was like, sure.
I want to leave Tokyo.
I'm just sick of Tokyo.
- How long were you there for?
like three or four days, right?
- Three days, yeah.
So the first day didn't really do...
Oh, the first day I went
out with him that night
and he took me to a bunch of girl bars,
which are not like hostess bars.
Cause hostess bars they sit next to you.
- Yeah.
- It's just like a bar where the girls
are on the other side.
Normally it's like 40
year old, 50 year old men.
Just like older men
- Yeah, from what I understand
is a girl bar's just
where the bartender,
whoever's like your waitress,
is just obligated to talk to you.
- Yeah.
- Is that right?
- Yeah, yeah, we went to a bunch though.
- It's like a really
expensive call center.
(Garnt laughs)
It's like one on one.
- Some of the prices weren't bad.
Like the first bar we went into,
the girls like only
spoke to the other girls.
Not like, I'm like
fucking pay me attention.
I just, I'd never been to one.
He was like, do you want to go to one?
He was like, do you want
to see you at them all?
And I'm like, sure, why not?
This will be a fun story
to tell in Trash Taste
which is worth more than money.
So, the first one was like
900 yen for 30 minutes.
- That's cheap.
- So you can drink as much as
you want in that 30 minutes.
And it went very slowly
because the people were no fun there.
(Garnt laughs)
But yeah,
- Clearly that, that explains the price.
- Yeah, yeah.
You just like banter with them.
Like one of them was saying
that they can't understand
English characters and in
Japanese I asked them like,
can you read Kanji?
And they were like, yes.
And then I was like, I rest my case.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- Why? as if like they
can't read the alphabet.
- Yeah, they've been studying
it for like five years
and couldn't read the English alphabet.
- What? how?
- And I'm like, yeah, exactly.
So I was like, so you can read
Kanji, right? in Japanese.
She's like, yes.
And I'm like, hmm.
(Garnt speaks foreign language)
- Yes, I said (Connor
speaks foreign language)
all the old dudes in the bar laugh.
And I'm like, hell yeah, dude.
And everyone clapped and stood up there.
- He saved the boys there.
- So then we left that bar
and immediately like four
people were like, yeah.
And I was like, oh nice,
you know these guys?
And he's like, no.
And I'm like, oh, we're following them?
He said, yeah, why not?
And I'm like, okay, cool.
- All right.
- So we're following them and
they take us to a bunny bar.
- Oh, like everyone's in a bunny costume.
- Is that what I think it is?
Everyone's just sitting in a bunny suit.
- Yeah, but due to COVID they
weren't in the bunny suits.
They were in bunny school girl outfits.
And I thought this is a cop-out
because they're wearing school outfits.
- But with the bunny ears.
- (mumbles) bunny ears.
- That's like every cosplay
who says they cosplay
and they just wear headbands.
- We walked in there and it was exactly
like what you think.
It looked like, to quote Joey,
a bunch of ugly bastards.
It was like 50 year old
men who looked like really,
really like...
- Just craving for attention, right?
- Yeah, and we sat down
and we looked at the prices
and it was like 50 bucks for 30 minutes.
- Jesus.
- So we were like, so
we're leaving, right?
Like we're not staying.
- Yeah.
- And then the here he
looked at me like, yep.
Yep, all right, cool.
So I'm just going to go
now, then you follow me.
So we just did that.
- So, leave before the
dudes saw us, right?
- Yeah, so we ditched the
guys who took us there
and they were like, whoa,
where are you going?
We be like, bye, bye,
bye, went to another bar.
That was a lot of fun.
We just spent all night, and then somehow
some sketchy dude was like
come to another bar I know.
No, we never met this guy.
- At what time of the night was this?
- Was like 2:00 AM.
- Okay.
- We got to take it to another bar.
And we get in there and
it's like a drag queen bar.
- Right.
- I'm like how? like proper gay bar.
And it was a lot of fun and yeah.
Sung Bohemian Rhapsody,
and I was butchering it.
And I knew the guy next to me was like,
you know, playing very nice.
Cause he was saying I was singing great.
And I'm like, no, no I'm not.
(Garnt laughs)
I'm like, are you alive, this is just.
- Yeah, it doesn't matter
who you're with, right?
No one can sing 'queen' well.
Everyone butchers 'queen'.
- I was like, you're a very attractive guy
but you don't need to lie to me.
You know what I mean?
- I know I'm butchering it.
- I know, I know I'm shit at this too.
You can't make this more obvious.
Then we just went to another bar
and just chat shit with people.
I feel like my Japanese got
way better when I was drinking.
- Yeah, I dunno why, but
it's the same as my Japanese,
as my Thai, where when I get
like a few drinks down me
somehow your language
skill was just improved
by like five folds.
I don't know why.
- You stop doubting yourself.
- Yeah.
- You just say shit.
- It's really weird
though because that works
for every language except English.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- It's so funny, like I
forget how to speak English.
So sometimes I just like run,
like when I get super drunk.
I noticed last time you
got drunk at the onsen,
you just like start speaking Japanese.
- Oh yeah.
- And I was like, I totally get that.
Cause when I get drunk, I just
start speaking Thai as well.
- Yeah, I'm just like, I don't know.
So many people have told me
like when I get blind drunk,
it doesn't matter if no one
around me can speak Japanese.
I only speak Japanese.
And I'm like really fucking proficient.
Like I'm reciting like fucking,
like MLK speech in Japanese.
And meanwhile if I go back to English
I'd just be like more drink here.
I just go cave man when I
go English, for some reason.
I don't know why.
- I brought a souvenir.
- Souvenirs?
- Little green being things.
- Kind of want to bring gifts.
- Well, just cause Joey brought.
- After I applied pressure to him.
All right, don't worry
folks, we found them.
They were just behind us the entire time.
- So, I'm guessing
because Joey started this.
Now we have to bring things
back when we go somewhere.
I was told this is a famous Niigata thing.
What is this Joey?
- It is sasa dango.
- Of course, I mean,
I can read that but...
- That's my favorite.
- But what is it Joey? tell us.
- I know of it.
I've heard of it before,
but I'd never actually...
- So, we dig in.
- So basically, this is banana leaves.
- Yeah.
- I'm pretty sure.
- Okay.
- And it's just like a
dango which is like a,
not a dumpling, what's the word for it?
- A red bean paste.
- Yeah, kind of like a red bean paste.
It's got red bean in it.
Yeah, but basically you
just crack this open.
I've never actually had one before.
I know what these are
because I've seen them around
because all sorts of different...
Cause I think there's
different types of sasa dango
for different areas of Japan.
- Wow, that's wow.
- That's (Joey speaks foreign
language) right there.
- Yeah, also for Joey's birthday,
I got him a bottle of wine.
- Oh, thank you.
- Which I don't know
which one you want Joey.
Then I bought one for
the Trash Taste boys.
These are both Niigata wines.
- Oh yeah, cause you stayed
in a onsen that had a winery
in it or something, right?
- I went to visit, I didn't stay in it,
cause it was like $800 a night and yeah,
Trash Taste ain't doing that well yet.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
But yeah, no.
So, I did try a lot of the
local wines while I was there
and I thought they were
actually pretty good.
And I thought, why not bring
back a wine for the boys?
- Yeah, I noticed with Japanese wine.
Cause I remember when I
went to, I can't remember,
I think it's Koshi Valley,
where it's kind of like
the Napa Valley of Japan.
And I tried a lot of the local wines there
and I find that Japanese
wines are either really good
or not so great.
I've never tried a Japanese
wine and I've just been like,
Hmm, this is like, this is okay.
- I love that this is
considered Japanese wine.
It's like, oh yes, my
favorite Japanese wine.
(Joey speaks foreign language)
I probably butchered that German.
It says Japan at the front though so...
- This is good, this is
like the weirdest unboxing
I've ever done.
But yeah, we are unboxing banana leafs.
- So you have to you,
because this thing is thick
you have to kind of
take it in small chunks.
Don't don't eat the whole thing
because you will choke on it
and possibly die.
- Are you serious?
- Oh, yeah, you know it's
like really common way
that people die here,
a lot of old people die
from choking on dango and mochi.
- What the fuck?
- Yeah.
- Health hazard.
- So I just bite into this thing?
- Yeah.
This reminds me of a Thai dish.
There's there's a Thai
dish of something similar.
- [Joey] Just take small chunks, yeah.
- Yeah, It's like, in Thailand
we have like banana leaves
that have like sticky rice
wrapped in banana leaves.
- It's actually pretty nice.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Oh, can I have the banana.
I'm not gonna eat it all at once.
- That does taste like a banana leaf.
- I like this.
- Yeah, it's pretty good.
- I just like the flavor though.
I mean, other than the red bean,
- I mean like, okay.
For anyone who hasn't
tried red bean paste.
It's, how do you describe to someone
who hasn't tried red bean paste before?
- Oh dude, it's weird.
I don't.
It's hard.
- But you guys like it, right?
- I like it, but it's..
- It's grown on me, red
bean paste is that one thing
where as like, I dunno,
somebody grew up in the West.
My idea of my idea of...
- Sweets.
- My idea of my idea of
like desserts or sweets,
basically just boiled down
to chocolate and ice cream.
- Right.
- I'm like, if I'm feeling
like super fancy or something,
something like a tiramisu or
cake or something like that,
having like red bean paste
and like mochi and stuff.
I'm like, man, this tastes really good.
- Yeah, I've always been fascinated
in the whole Japanese
sweets, like culture I guess.
- It gets weird man, they
go crazy with sweets.
- It's called wagashi, for
those of you want to know.
But like dango, mochi,
that kind of stuff is like,
it's weird because a lot of wagashi,
a lot of Japanese sweets
can either be sweet
or depending on what you put with it,
they can also be savory.
So it's like a weird, cause
like this for example,
it's sweet, but it's not
like a chocolate sweet
or like a tiramisu sweet.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- It's almost a savory
sweet, if that makes sense.
But I mean, like my dad, for instance,
can't eat red bean paste
just because, it's weird,
he likes the flavor, but he
doesn't like the texture.
- Yeah, it's super, super thick.
It's just basically
- It's like grainy, right?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Almost.
- It's like sludgy.
I don't know.
- We're throwing a lot
of different adjectives
out and then none of them are matching
- It's because like
there's nothing I can point
to in like that people can
just ground that texture with
in like the West or something.
It's just something, it's
thicker than ice cream
but it's a bit like pasty as well.
I don't fucking know.
I'm just doing it.
I'm doing an awful job.
- Just try it out.
- Like, the one dessert
I haven't enjoyed as much
as I thought I would have,
like based on the hype
that everyone talks about
it, is a shaved ice.
Japanese shaved ice.
- Is shit.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- It's basically just
like a Japanese version
of a snow cone.
Essentially.
- People fucking love
it here and I'm like,
just get an ice cream.
- Yeah, like.
- Sometimes you don't want ice cream,
sometimes you want something
a little more refreshing
than an ice cream.
- I don't know.
Like, cause here there
are some shaved ice places
that people will line up
to for fucking an hour.
- Okay, I don't get that shit.
Like I'll just fucking make it at home.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Like I'm not going to
like, cause there are some
shaved ice places that are like,
there's stores that
specialize in shave ice.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And I'm like, what's the difference
between making it at home? making it here?
Cause like Meilyne fucking
- [Garnt] Of course.
- Cause she's a food
critic, right? our producer.
She's like, I found this
like amazing shaved ice place
but there's like a two
hour line every day.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I'm like, why are
people lining up for it?
And she's like, oh, it's like fluffy.
That's not what I look for in a shave
- After like two minutes,
after you've been given,
it all just starts melting to the point
where it just doesn't taste good.
- It's just slush.
- Yeah.
- It's having a slush puppie
with extra sugar on it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I don't like it, the
places when they just have
like chocolate sauce squirted on shit.
Like how can you sit there
and tell me something is worth
two hours wait, when
you've just got a bottle
of like chocolate squeeze shit on it.
- Like how does squeeze
chocolate take long.
- You literally have to put
chocolate sauce on water
and people lining up
two hours for this shit.
Are you kidding me?
Like gelato, that shit is amazing, man.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- I love that shit, so fresh.
- I like gelato.
- Gelato gang rice.
- Oh no, I absolutely love,
I had like proper authentic gelato.
- What do you mean it's all right.
What the fuck do you mean it's all right
- I had to stop my thoughts
and I'm like, excuse me.
- It's just thick ice cream.
Let's be honest guys.
Let's not build this up.
- That's the best part.
- You have one fucking
bite, you're like, man,
I'll just have three
course meal and I'm good.
- I had legit, like, I don't
wanna say, we'd say home grown.
- In Italian?
- I had a legit gelato
in Florence in Italy
and that shit was the fucking bomb.
- Oh, yeah, it's the best.
- I thought gelato here and
like in Australia was good.
But then I had it in Florence I'm like,
damn this hits different.
- Italians, man, they know
how to make fucking gelato.
- They know how to make good gelato.
- I love you, just keep it gelato.
- Yeah, Florence just keep making gelato.
- Never change, never change.
Yeah, but I dunno like,
are there any other,
like Japanese sweets that you guys like.
- Melon pan scrape.
- Melon pan?
Is that considered a sweet?
- Yeah.
- I mean, that just goes back
to the bread conversations
where like a lot of things
just happen to be sweet sweets.
But are they really sweets?
- It's more of a sweet
than bread, I'd say.
- Yeah.
- Well, things like melon pan
and like chocolate coronets
are considered like cush
bang which is sweet bread
or like a confectionary bread.
That's what it's called.
Yeah, chocolate coronets.
Like the eye corneas?
- No, no.
- That's what I thought as well.
- No, no, no.
Chocolate coronets are like
the ones that the fucking
cornets eat in 'lucky star'.
- Oh, those ones?
- Like the little like
swirly with the chocolate.
- The poopy ones?
- The poopy ones, yeah.
(Joey laughing.)
- They look like poop.
- It's the poopy bread, right?
- You bite it and then
the black shit comes out
and it's just like, okay.
- I'll show you, but
you've definitely seen it.
It's got like the big hole at the bottom
where they squeeze the chocolate into
and the entire debate, like 'Lucky Star'
started this entire
debate of like which side
do you eat the chocolate
cornet from, the fat end
or the thick end.
The entire first episode
of lucky star is that
That's how an anime opens.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Yeah, but it's great.
There's lots of those
kinds of bread in Japan.
And then there's like
the savory bread, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But for some reason they
also make the savory bread
sweet in a sense.
So, I just don't...
- There's just nothing
that's savory in Japan.
- There's just nothing savory.
And when it comes to bread,
there's nothing savory.
It's Weird enough like this kind of shit
is more savory sometimes.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Than the bread that you get.
- What'd you want? something savory.
Okay, so just a little bit of sugar.
It's like, no, no, no, no sugar.
So just one teaspoon of sugar.
Is that what you're talking about?
- It goes back to the whole
like Thai dish no spice, right?
It's like, what do you mean
no spice in a Thai dish?
- That's not an option.
- It's like, one chili, right?
- But like I noticed with Japan,
there's so many different types of sweets.
And I feel like it's because
of the gift giving culture
here, because there
seems to be like a gift
for every occasion and every
kind of relationship you have.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So dumb, so dumb
- There's, my favorite example of just
the gift giving culture
that is just way too intense
is a Valentine's day in Japan.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, well, I mean there's,
there's the whole concept
of like Valentine's day,
which is on the usual,
February 14th and then there's White day,
which is March 14th.
- See, the only reason I
know this is because of anime
because there's the one
episode in every romance
or harem anime where
like the girl or the guy
is just rushing to get
some fucking chocolate
for the other guy.
- The girl is always like she's
just making the chocolate,
has to stay up all night
and the chocolate sucks
but the main protagonist is
like, no, it's still good.
It doesn't matter because
she poured her heart
and soul into this.
- It's one week before, right?
- What?
- White day?
- No white day is March 14th.
It's a month after.
So what it is is...
- It's after? Oh, fuck.
- Yeah, so Valentine's day traditionally,
in every other country,
is guys give chocolates
to the girls, girls give
chocolates to the guys, right?
All that kind of shit.
- Yeah.
- That's the traditional way.
- I think so.
But in Japan, Valentine's
day is specifically
a day where the girls give
chocolates to the guys.
- Now this is right,
because I remember this.
I was like six, you get like
a month to analyze that gift.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like all right, how
much am I going to spend?
- Yeah, and then white day.
(Garnt laughs)
- Connor gets out his spreadsheet
and he's just like, okay.
- You have a month to optimize.
- What's the worst thing
about having you're both going
to buy a gift for each other
at the exact same time.
- This is why I hate Christmas.
- No, exactly.
- This is why I fucking hate Christmas.
- Because, right, you have
to like either mind read
each other like, how much
is he going to spend?
Or you got to just straight
it, be like max 20 quids.
You're saying max 20 quid?
- Yeah.
- So that's great because...
- I hate having the
conversation before Christmas.
She's like, yeah, we're
setting a budget on this.
- What budget?
- This is our budget.
- So that's great, I remember this.
Cause then I got a gift
and I was like sick.
So I can just either
not give you a gift back
if I don't see you again in the moment.
Or I can plan it out,
what I'm gonna give you.
- Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
So yeah, usually it's
the whole idea of like,
the guy has to give an equal amount
or because Japan is always like this...
- One up.
- The guys have to one up the girls.
- Or just say psych and
don't date her anymore.
- True, but here's the thing right?
In Japanese Valentine's day.
I know it cause I made
a whole video on this.
There's three different types
of chocolates you can give.
- Really?
- Yeah.
So there's okay.
So there's honmei choco,
which is the chocolate
that a girl gives to a guy who
the girl like really likes,
it's like the one basically.
And then there's giri
choco, which is a chocolate
that a girl gives to a guy
that she has had some kind
of like, non platonic relationship with.
- Someone literally just
saw the Apple pricing
for the phone.
Let's do that with chocolate.
- Yeah, pretty much.
So basically giri choco is like, say like,
if like, Meilyne, for example, right.
She's out producer.
Like we, aren't together.
So, she would give us giri
choco, because we work together.
We're involved in her life in some way.
- Is there ever a point
where you're like, stop?
I can't eat this chocolate,
this is giri choco.
We need to go above this.
- Exactly, I can't believe you
thought about me like this.
I thought we were closer than this.
- Like yeah.
And then there's that right?
And traditionally that's where it ended.
But recently, there's a third
type of chocolate called
tomo choco, which is where
girls will give chocolates
to other girls who they're friends with.
- I hate this.
- Oh my God.
- So Japan is somehow just fucking.
- They've spreadsheet chocolate.
- They've spreadsheet advances.
- It's spread sheeting gifts.
Because I had a conversation last week
with someone who is like
the manager of Teddy Lloyd,
one of Meilyne's friend.
And she was telling me about how she,
like every time she has a new
clients or someone she has
to manage, she, Japanese
culture is that they have to
give a gift.
So she goes to this
department store to like,
get this gift for this
new band or something.
And then the department
clerk literally asks them,
Okay, how well do you know them?
What's your relationship with them?
And then she answers that.
And then the next question was,
so where are you giving it to them?
Are you giving it to the
dressing room (Joey laughs)
or are you giving it in the office?
- Who cares.
Like she literally had to
had a fucking spreadsheet,
apparently, she pulls
out a catalog depending
on what answers she was given
to give the perfect gift.
- This is extreme floaters, Jesus.
- And I mean, it's just like,
dude, it's just some fucking,
at the end of the day, it's
just a bunch of sweets.
You know what I mean?
- You know what this is the equivalent of?
This is equivalent to like doing those
personality questionnaires
at the start of RPGs
to see like which partner you get.
But then after you fill it
out, you have all the options
open to you anyway.
That's exactly what it is.
- It's the fucking Facebook quiz.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- Which character are you?
- Which Valentine's day gift are you?
Japan has not only done
this with Valentine's day.
They've done it for like Christmas,
they've done it for like Halloween.
They've done it for everything.
They've just completely
somehow made everything
like a million times more
complicated than it should be.
- It's as if life here
isn't stressful enough.
- [Joey] Yeah, right?
- With all the paperwork you
gotta fill out for everything.
- And then you got shit
like oseibo and ochugen,
which is like giving gifts at
like certain times of the year
and shit to people.
- This is why I'm glad that we don't work
exactly in an office environment.
- Oh, fuck.
- Oh, no.
- Like we work with people
who understand foreign culture
and everything like that.
So I don't have to...
Because if I'm working
in a Japanese company
I'd be so fucking stressed out.
- I'm doing my work, not
fucking up with gifts.
- Imagine going to a company party
- Oh, fuck.
- or going to like a
company drinking session.
And you just don't know how to act.
Cause that's me, right?
- Jesus.
- Like only in Japan
will you go to the office
and you're more stressed out
about your like social status
than you are the actual work
that you're involved in.
- Like I'm stressed enough
thinking am I giving them
my business card the right way?
- Oh, yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- There's rules to that as well.
- There's rules to that.
I just want to like swap business
cards, but no, it's like,
is it pointed the right way?
we have to give it at the same time.
- I had the situation where I had to give
my business cards recently
and I had a mailing mix up.
So I had like a 1,000 IQ move.
I'm like, no, no, no,
my manager will do it.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
I'm not.
I'm like, I'm not giving my business card.
My manager will give you a business card.
- I do that some of the time.
Every time we're in the business meeting
I'm like Meilyne take it, swap contact.
Do the thing manager.
- It's the opposite for
me because she knows
that I can speak Japanese.
So she waits for me to go first.
- But in reality, I've just
forgotten my business cards.
(Garnt laughs)
I don't carry them with me, man.
Cause I don't want to carry
them with me all the time.
- Because you have to have a
separate business card holder.
And I've not gotten to the point
where I have enough business meetings
where I could be networking
at any point all the time.
And it just looks tacky.
If you just put out your business card
and it's in your beaten ass wallet
with 20 other million cards in it,
that just doesn't look cool.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know one bullshit rule
I found out the other day in Japan.
If I want to leave my apartment building
for more than two weeks,
I need to get permission.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is it more than two weeks for you?
- Yeah.
- For us it's a month.
- More than two weeks.
I got to get like permission
to leave my house.
- Oh yeah, that is.
- You didn't know why that's
the case though, right?
- Why is that the case?
- It's because there's
a lot of cases in Japan
of people running away.
- Oh.
- They leave the house space,
they basically escape from their lives.
- Supposed to have a
guarantor or something.
- Well, no, it's the guarantor
who can't chase you up.
- Then the guarantor has to pay, right?
Is that the whole point?
- No, no, you, you, you send
the money to the guarantor
and then the guarantor has to pay.
But if you're not sending
any money to the guarantor
then the guarantor can't do anything.
- Oh, I thought the whole
point was the guarantor pays
if you can't pay.
- That's if the guarantor is nice enough.
- I guess I can understand if
they're worried about that.
But then also, I don't know,
it's just weird living in the UK.
I don't know, It just
seems like I'd never want
to have to ask if I can leave.
- Yeah, sure.
- That's weird.
- You have to ask
permission to do everything.
- Two weeks?
That seems like a little, a
month I can kind of understand.
- Yeah.
- I mean, yeah.
- So yeah, so like every
time Aki and I go to the US,
for example, like last year,
before the whole pandemic
thing, when we were in America
for like three months
at a time or something.
I have to call them up.
I mean, it's super easy.
- I can imagine though.
They never say no.
- No.
- But it's just weird though
that they might say like,
no, you can't go.
- Well, I mean, for us it's
easy, because I just say,
oh, it's for work.
And they're like, okay.
- Yeah.
- They don't question it.
But if it's like, I have to
attend an animate convention,
then maybe they'll be like, hmm.
- If they were like
grilling you I'd be like,
mind your own fucking business, I pay you.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like, oh my gosh.
I remember I saw a few
comments that are like,
man kind of hates Japan.
Why is he even there.
He's so ungrateful man.
And I was like, nah, I want to...
- Privileged.
- I guess we do often point out the things
that we don't like about Japan a lot.
But that's because I think a lot of people
in my mind view Japan as
this like utopian country.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And at the end of the day
it's like any other
country that has issues.
- And also because, I think
that we've experienced
living here as opposed
to just listening here.
You can't get a scope of a
country just from visiting it.
- But, I mean, we have
complaints about any country.
- We're British, I mean,
I'm going to complain about anything.
I'll find a complaint
about something I love.
- I love it, but fuck, I hate it.
- Yeah exactly.
When I lived in Thailand
there were like so many things
that I didn't like about living there.
But there's things I
fucking loved as well.
So it's all like a give
and take wherever you live.
It's funny, right?
Cause when I was a kid, I
was like I want to live in A.
I want to live in X.
It'd be cool if I lived there.
But like the more you move
around and the more I travel,
the less I know where
I want to settle down.
Cause like the more I travel,
the more I'm like, man,
I really love this one
thing about that one place.
But man, I really hate that
one thing about that one place,
so really wants me to like,
I dunno, this COVID situation
has just made me feel
trapped in this country.
- For sure, for sure.
- This has probably been
like one of the longest
I've gone through in my entire life
without flying somewhere.
- Yeah, yeah. I mean, yeah.
I dunno like for me as well,
like this is the longest
I've been in Japan for like
an extended period of time
without going anywhere.
And I've definitely, I don't know.
I haven't noticed anything
new about or new about
you know, like any of the
good parts about living here
or any of the bad parts.
- Yeah.
- But, I dunno.
It's made me appreciate the
things that I really like
and fucking despise
the things that I hate.
- True, true.
- It's like to another level.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I wake up every day
and I walk past my router
and I just smile, I'm like damn.
Damn, I have a gigabyte
download and upload.
That's just beautiful,
I love to see it, dude.
- I don't know why I heard you say Naruto.
- I sit by and I'm like, damn you're good.
- Damn, damn.
- You do your job good.
- Yeah.
- You can, fucking sucks the internet.
- You're talking to the Australian here.
- Oh yeah, sure
- Don't don't talk to me
until you have experienced
a point four upload.
- No dude, cause in fucking
Wales, man, you would get like.
- Yeah, but you live in the
middle of fucking nowhere.
- Right, so you would,
they'd be like, oh yeah,
we only have copper wire by the way.
We're not going to put
any other wire down.
Here's your 0.1 download that
doesn't work half the time.
And it's like, cool.
And then they charge you like
fucking $80 a month for it.
And it's like, okay, why?
It doesn't work.
- That's what it was
like for us in Australia.
We had copper wires everywhere.
- Yeah, and then did they say that like,
oh, someone will come on this
day and then no one turns up.
- No.
- That happened so many
times, or they turn up,
they'd be like yeah, we're
gonna send somebody to fix it.
They turn up and they're like,
yeah, I have no idea what's wrong with it.
- Like especially in Australia, the whole,
if I were to sum up the whole
like just service business
side of things in one
phrase would just be,
that was a fucking lie.
Because they never show.
Like the service men
never show up on time.
Transport never fucking shows up on time.
- Yeah.
- Like, oh my God, the
Australia, the Sydney transport.
I don't know about
other parts of Australia
but Sydney transport had
to be one of the worst
I've ever experienced.
- [Connor] Really?
- Okay, so I had to catch
a bus every day to go
to uni, all right?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And this bus turns up every 20 minutes.
That's what it says on
the timetable at the stop.
So I'm like, okay, cool.
This next one's coming in 10 minutes.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- 10 minutes passes, no
bus, like not a single bus.
I'm like, did I miss it
while I was looking down at my phone?
Where is it?
- Right.
- All right, whatever.
Another 10 minutes doesn't show up.
Like, okay.
But then five minutes before
the next bus shows up,
the previous bus shows up.
- [Connor] Right, right.
- But, because the bus is full.
It doesn't stop.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So I'm like, not only
are you 15 minutes late
but this motherfucker
didn't even stop for me.
(Garnt laughs)
- Dude, you can have
that in Wales as well.
This boy is lucky, he grew up in a city.
- Yeah.
- I mean, I did too technically.
- Oh, shit.
- He grew up in Sydney.
- I grew up in Sydney.
- What the fuck?
- Which is like the biggest city.
- One of the biggest city of Australia
- So like, my bus, that was
the one that I used to get
if I want to go to England, like Chester.
I would have to get this bus.
And it was every 30 minutes.
Problem was, is that it
was always give or take
30 minutes late.
Like 30 minutes late or early.
So you basically had like
to go there and wait.
And like, if it said like, half, three,
it would just turn up at four.
- Yeah.
- And then you were like is
this the next bus that's early?
Or is it this bus that's late?
I don't know.
It's basically fucking madness.
Yeah, it was bad as well
because not only was sometimes
the bus is late but
sometimes the bus would come
five minutes early because I don't know.
It just happened to run
all the traffic lights.
- Like, it wasn't really a schedule.
It was just like a rough estimate of time.
- It's like a recommended route,
like we should probably get here...
- Yeah, recommended time of arrival.
- Yeah, just stick around though.
Fuck those kids.
Yeah, and it's the same
with like package deliveries
in the UK.
I hated it, because they would say,
between 8:00 AM and 8:00 PM.
And it's like, wow.
So I just got to be at the
house the whole fucking day?
- 12 hours.
- Because you've just said Tuesday,
like that is eight to eight.
You know what I mean?
And they wouldn't even turn
up on that day sometimes.
So it's like what is he, what is...
- Meanwhile, here in
Japan we just got a couch
for the office just this morning.
And we set it for 12:00 PM to 2:00 PM.
- Yeah.
- Two hour window, perfect.
- The couch arrives at 1201.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And they phoned you as well.
- They phone you to
make sure that you're in
and they can come and
everything and it's beautiful.
- And if you miss it, you
can also just reschedule.
Say, if you miss it like 8:00 AM,
you can reschedule it the same day
for it to come at like 4:00 PM.
Which is like insane, because
in the UK, if you miss it,
it's like, right, well, next
month we have a schedule.
We have a slot three, and it's like, what?
It was horrible pre-ordering games.
And the games turn up like four days late
and then you might miss it
and they just wouldn't post
it through the letter box.
So you got to call them up or go online
and then they'd be like,
oh we have a free slot
in five days.
It's like, five days, I bought this game,
what do you mean five days.
- See, because back when
I was living in Australia
I know I've got a lot
of comments about this
but we have Amazon now in Australia.
But back when I was living in Australia,
- Congratulations.
- Yeah, I know, we finally got it.
Because people are like, Joey,
what are you talking about?
we do have Amazon.
Back when I was living in
Australia, we didn't have Amazon.
Back in my days, we didn't have Amazon.
- Joey is an Australian boomerang.
- I'm an Australian boomerang.
- Back in my day.
- Back in my day, we
didn't have Amazon yet.
Like Amazon's only like a
recent thing that got introduced
to Australia, because we only had eBay.
- Yeah, wow.
- Why would you use eBay for anything?
- Yeah, like I still have
never experienced Amazon now
or the comforts of like
living in a place where
you can just get your
package literally hours off.
- Oh, it's beautiful.
- Order it.
- I mean, especially
coming from me, who'd never
experienced Amazon until moving to Japan.
The first week of me
experiencing Amazon I was like,
I feel like a God.
Like I can just get things
delivered now, without having to
wait arduous amounts of time.
- Yeah, I don't know
how people move to Japan
before Amazon existed as
like a Gaijin, oh my God.
- I don't know.
- I don't know for like...
I guess my house just
wouldn't be furnished
for like a month, I guess
or even more and fuck knows
how I would just get
like normal necessities
that I just can't find in stores.
- Right. It's like, oh, you
know, I need a phone charger.
I couldn't just, you know, go
on Amazon, get it delivered,
probably the same day.
Or I could trek 30 minutes
by train to the closest
big camera to buy one measly cable.
Why would I do that?
- Tokyo doesn't have this, but London did.
London had Amazon now
and it was basically
like two hour windows.
- Yeah.
- You could, if you ordered
it, it would come in two hours.
- Oh, wow.
- Yeah, it was pretty good.
- I was just saying...
- Like expedited shipping?
- Yeah, like sometimes we
would be at a house party
and we'd run out of alcohol
and like instead of going
to the Tesco we'd literally
just order our alcohol
off Amazon and it would just
turn up like an hour later
when we were like low on beers.
- Yeah, yeah.
- This is the future.
- Yeah, like a whole crate.
And then also, like I remember
I ordered a crate of beer
and like a Nintendo switch
game and I was like sick.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
So I was like...
- They're like who ordered this?
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Yeah, like who ordered a
fucking Mario Party Super?
So, Super Mario Party
and I'm like, that's me.
- It was at the bottom of the box.
- Just really wanted to play Mario Party.
- I'm just fucking jealous of the guy
in the other room playing Mario.
I really wanted it, man.
- That's awesome though.
- I think on that incident,
it was quicker to get it
delivered on Amazon now,
than it was to download it.
- Oh, wow.
- Because the download is a piece of shit.
- Oh yeah, yeah, true, true.
- That's like first world
problems in a nutshell.
Download too slow, just
order it off Amazon.
It's slightly faster
- Because when I used to make long videos,
I had to leave my PC on all
night and a bit on the next day.
I couldn't use it.
I distribute upload
files for Evan to edit,
I would have to leave it on all night.
Hoping that when I woke
up, they were all uploaded.
Otherwise I probably would
be able to use my PC.
- Right.
So, yeah, that was a pain in the ass.
Now I just upload it in one hour.
- Because that's the one with
the copper wiring, right?
Is that like when you're
using an upload, for example,
like really heavily, the
download has to compensate
for the upload.
So yeah.
So like every time I
would like upload a video
at like 1:00 AM, right?
I couldn't use the internet
because I had legitimately
like fucking dial up speed.
- I was about to say going
back to dial up at this point.
- It was legitimately dial up speed.
It took like two minutes
to load up Twitter
and I'm just like, I
can't, I can't do this.
- I can't live like this.
- I can't do this man.
Why would you do this to me?
- Yeah, it's crazy.
And they said like, the
companies used to throttle
my internet all the fucking time.
- God, were you a Virgin.
- Yeah.
- Fucking virgin man
- Virgin media fucking sucks.
- My God, what a version company?
- They would really have
closed shop because, on paper
they give you the best internet speeds.
- 100 megabytes download.
Never fucking saw it once.
- You never see it.
And at peak times, man, you
are not getting anywhere close,
near to what they advertise to you.
- The moment you upload or
download anything as well
they immediately throttle
you and had to call them up
so many times like,
hey, turn that shit off.
I paid for this.
And they charge you so much.
- We're going back to the days of dial up
where you have to be like,
mom, get off the phone,
I'm downloading a game.
- I had to that to my little brother
when I used to play league
at home, I'd be like,
and my ping would go
from like maybe 66, 150.
I'm like get off the fucking phone.
- I remember back in university,
whenever you were living
in like a shared house, my God,
trying to game in a shared
house is fucking impossible.
Cause yeah, your ping
would either be like 10,
when no one's awake or
when it's dinner time,
it's like fucking 800.
I'm like, who's fucking downloading
another episode of 'Game of Thrones'.
Everyone's a fucking duck.
Everyone's torrenting.
- Everyone puts their hands up.
- It was fucking worse for me because
when I was doing YouTube,
like way back in Australia,
all of my YouTuber friends
were in America, right?
So every time I'd jumped onto
like G-mode or something,
on a good day, my ping would be like 300.
I'd be like, guys...
- Why even play a 300 pings?
- Cause I was desperate for friends.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
I didn't have any YouTuber
friends in Australia.
- There must be a Formula
for like ping correlation
with how desperate you are
to hang out with that person.
Because I play league of legends
a lot with Titus and Emily
and it's like 200 ping.
And I'm like, man, this
sucks, but it's really fun.
- Oh yeah, I mean 300
pings G-mode was still fun.
But I mean, yeah, no one could kill me
because I just keep fucking teleporting.
- What is the value of friendship, right?
- Is it 300 pings.
- What is your ping limit for us?
- We should break down
the value of friendship
by ping number.
(Joey laughs)
Like, would I pay 160 ping for you?
Yeah, I'll pay you for that.
- 800 ping, ultimate friend.
100 ping, just an acquaintance.
- I just wanna talk to you, man.
- Yeah, so you used to upload daily
on that garbage internet.
- I sure did.
- Oh my God.
- And that's why my
computer exploded, remember?
- How did you not get like
burned out, from that.
I think I would like hey,...
- I mean, I did get burned out,
after like two and a
half years of doing that.
Because I quit Let's Plays a
week before I moved to Japan.
- I remember when you quit
that and I thought like, good.
- Yeah, everyone was like, good.
You should have done that.
And I think I did it at the perfect time
because that was just around
the time, like early 2015.
That was around the time when gaming
was kind of starting to dip.
- Yeah.
- Like just overall, that's when YouTube
kind of shafted all of gaming.
YouTube was like no
more spotlight for you.
- Yeah, that's around 2015.
- Which like speaking
about that, have you guys
in your YouTube careers, ever
properly experienced burnout?
- Oh yeah.
- When was the last time you
guys experienced burnout?
- Last time I experienced
like proper burnout was maybe,
this was back before I
was leaving with Aki.
- [Garnt] Right.
- And I was just living on my own.
And yeah, I just had like a moment,
like maybe for like half a year
where I was just constantly,
like all I was thinking
about was like, all right.
What's the next video?
What's the next one?
I just keep one upping myself.
And like just coming up with
ideas because even back then,
I think it was maybe uploading like once
every three days or something.
So not as intense as daily
but it's still pretty intense.
Especially because now I wasn't
doing Let's Plays anymore.
I was doing like straight up like,
I was writing a script every fucking day.
So that shit burnt me
out like a hell of a lot.
And there was like a point
where I was legitimately like,
should I just like stop?
Like, should I just stop
YouTube for a while?
- Yeah.
- But then I was like,
nah, ain't worth it.
- I think a lot of
people view us here a lot
about like, the mystical
YouTube burnout, what it means,
like, can you like try to explain.
- At this point, I'm sure
for a viewer hearing burnout
was just like, oh let's just get that
off the YouTuber checklist.
It's kind of just become a cliche now.
It's like, oh, you reached burnout.
Okay, okay.
- All right, see you in a couple of days,
you'll be over it soon.
Like people think that
YouTuber burnout is just like,
like I dunno
- Woe is me.
- Yeah, kind of a woe is me,
like a very privileged
first-world problem.
But I think it's just another
form of like creative burnout.
And if you've never experienced
burnout in your life
or create a burnout, artists
block is another word for it.
It's essentially where
you want to do something
and you want to make
something, but you either
have no motivation or
no inspiration to do,
or both sometimes.
You're just like, man, I
really want to get a video out.
I know I need to get a video out.
I want to be creative.
I just don't know what to do.
- Yeah.
- And I have no motivation for it.
I think there's one person
who reached burnout recently.
Then they made a statement about it
and like hit me hard because...
So the author of "Tower of
God" recently went on hiatus
for like an indefinite period of time.
So we don't know, he hasn't said,
I'm going to be away for this long.
He actually just wrote like
a really really long post
just detailing that
he's just had no breaks
for this entire like time
during "Tower of gods".
And I remember there was
one line that really hit me
which was, I think he said, I didn't know
whether I was working to
upload or uploading to work.
No, no.
I didn't know whether
I was living to upload
or upload to live.
You know what I mean?
And I'm just like, dude,
I totally get that, man.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- Because there are times during burnout
where you're just like, man
- What am you doing?
- What am I doing?
Am I even enjoying this anymore?
- So I mean, to explain to the viewers,
how do you like get into burnout?
Like, how do you, like,
what does it feel like?
Like, like how does it start?
- It happens in so many different ways.
I feel really depends
on the person, but like,
a common thing that would
happen is, for example,
like if you uploaded
like four or five videos
that are like absolute bangers, right.
It's just like, boom, views,
boom views, boom, views.
And then after that really good streak
you have another streak, but
in the opposite direction
of like, oh, that one bombed, oh,
that one bombed even harder.
Oh, that one bombed even harder.
And you start to lose self
motivation and like you start to,
I dunno, it's really hard
to explain, isn't it?
You don't realize creative burnout started
until you're deep in creative burnout.
- Yeah, it's really hard
to see the early signs
of creative burnout.
Sometimes it's just, you just
wake up and you just do a job.
And then eventually like
five months down the line
you're like, man, I've
just been feeling the same.
Exactly the same this entire five months.
And I'm just not getting
anything new out of this.
- I'm sure, like most people
who just work normal jobs
get it as well with their own job
where they just kind of feel light,
like, hmm, do I like this or?
Like, I know a lot of people
don't like what they do
and they just do it to survive
because they don't have a choice.
I mean, we're very lucky
that we do something that is,
most people would say
it's pretty fun, right?
- Yeah.
- And it's very...
- And no doubt it is.
- It's definitely like,
it's a very hard job
and I'm not in like any
manual intensive kind of way,
but like, yeah, we're
working so fucking hard.
It's a hard job, like mentally,
but still definitely by far
like the best job I've ever had.
I couldn't think of a job
that would give me this much freedom.
- No, I wouldn't replace
this for anything.
- Which is why we haven't quit.
But in terms of pure work hours.
I know for a fact, I
put more hours working,
like actual working in this
job unlike any previous job.
- Oh, easily.
- And it's because you
can never switch off.
And I think this is the
same war for anyone.
Who's like self-employed, where,
especially in our position
where our jobs stemmed from our hobby.
So do you ever get that point
when you're kind of watching
an anime and you can or reading a manga
and there's just that
little voice in the back
of your head that says, you
can make a video out of this.
You can make a video out of this,
instead of just like
reading it for platitude.
- Yeah, that's why I've completely,
over the last two years or so.
I've had a complete anime
burnout, just for that.
Like, I've stopped.
Like I'm sure my viewers
can easily see that,
I have not been talking about
recent animate whatsoever.
When people ask, hey,
have you watched this?
Hey, have you watched this recent stuff?
I always say, nope, nope.
I'll get to it.
I'll get to it, because I
have that thing of like,
I could just watch this
for my own entertainment.
But at the same time, I feel
like I'm wasting my time
if I don't make a video on it.
- Yeah.
- I don't know.
That's my biggest fear,
is just wasting time.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I dunno, like, whenever I
feel like I'm wasting time,
I just can't lose myself in
like any show or something.
And for anime, that's times
10, because I can never
just watch an anime
just for purely watching
an anime anymore.
That's made watching
anime and reading manga
10 times harder.
Cause if I feel like I don't
get anything out of this,
either like for entertainment
wise or if I see something
I can't talk about or something like that,
then I just cant get
myself to focus in there.
Like recently I just
watched the good place,
which is like a live
action show on Netflix.
- You watch live action?
- Yeah.
- What?
- I did something I hadn't
done in a long time.
And I watched all four
seasons, in like a few days.
- Oh, wow.
- I'm like, what the fuck did I just do?
How did I?
I didn't know I had this in me.
Remember when I watched one
piece in like two weeks.
- I can watch.
- I can still binge stuff.
My God
- It's weird, cause I think
the hardest part is like,
when I used to work at
McDonald's and I used to go home
and I got to watch anime
or play video games.
- Yeah.
- It was just like totally different.
I didn't have to worry about McDonald's.
- You didn't have to second guess, right?
Like you could just be
like, immediately like,
I'm watching anime.
- And I think the hard
part about burnout is that,
instead of like the job
being difficult itself
is that it creeps into
every aspect of your life.
Because YouTube is more often than not
themselves is the product.
Like, we're like the brand, if you will.
You know, like even just,
if I go out for a meal,
I'm like, hmm, am I wasting potential
by not posting about
this and what I'm doing?
- Yeah.
It's like, everything in
your life is like infected
with this thought of like,
should I try and monetize this?
- It's the point where
everything in your life
becomes a commodity, even experiences.
Like even experiences
can become a commodity
or like in our cases it could
become like a nice fun story
on Trash Taste and that kind of thing.
Where everything, you start
thinking about everything
in your life in terms of your
job and how it can affect
your YouTube, or how you
can use that to benefit.
And it gets to a point sometimes
where it just becomes subconscious.
- Which is why I never
understood the mentality
of people who do like
daily vlogs of their lives.
- My God.
- How do you do that?
- I think you have to be a psychopath.
- I think you do, you
have to be psychopathic
or sociopathic or a combination.
- You definitely lose something.
Like my relationship with anime and manga
has forever been changed.
Like I still love anime and
manga, but my relationship
with it has been forever changed
because that to me is
content, that to me is my job.
- It's work material.
- Imagine if your entire life was content.
- I mean,
- My God.
- This is why like, all the like, cut,
like vlogging couples always
going to breaking up, right?
Because of course you have to break up
because your whole relationship
is the YouTube channel.
- Yeah.
- Your whole relationship is
determined by the algorithm.
- Yeah, and it's basically,
how long you stay together
is how long is the money worth it.
After you get so rich it's like,
at what point do you
need this extra money?
- Yeah.
- Let's be honest.
Like if you already have like two houses.
- Yes, that's fucking
crazy, like, I've seen,
say like there are some
family vloggers, for example,
that have been going on
for like, five, 10 years.
And I'm just like, how are
you guys like, okay, mentally?
Cause that would drive me fucking insane.
- Yeah.
- Because like, I get insane
just from going to a bookstore
and being like, all right,
I've got to find my next video.
Let alone, you do that
every moment of your life,
you'd be like, all right,
what's something I can like
pick up and show on camera.
To like show them that
we're living a normal life.
- Also as well, whenever I've
hung out with like YouTubers
it's normally always like the
newer ones or the smaller ones
who always want to like take
a picture and post everything.
Because I think that they
haven't like experienced it yet.
cause if you were hanging
out with big YouTubers
they're ever like, oh, let's
post this on social media.
Let's take a picture of the post.
It's always like, oh,
we're not, I don't know.
It's just like this kind
of vibe that you get around
some people where you're
like, all right, cool.
This is just going to be a private thing.
Nothing's going to be like,...
- Yeah.
Weirdly, it's like, you usually have to,
if you're interacting
with a bigger YouTuber
you usually have to be
the one to be like, hey,
is it okay if I upload this?
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
I would ask, I mean, if I'm
within a bigger YouTuber,
and for some reason wanted
to post what I was doing
at that moment in time, I
would ask them, but I never do.
I always like it, like
a side when I'm like
someone pulls out a camera
are they're gonna post it.
I'm like, all right.
- Yeah.
- All right.
- We're gonna do that thing, here we go.
- I just wanted to eat dinner, but fine.
Let's turn them into something.
Like, cause to me it's like,
the only hundred percent escape I get.
It's just like a nice fucking meal.
I don't know why.
I fucking love food.
- You just like food man.
- I fucking love food.
- I mean, who doesn't?
- To me, like food is, talking about,
very tasty, very delicious.
And I can eat a lot.
- I'd like to think so, yes.
- Right, but for me, my
favorite part about food
is like the social aspect of food
and like eating with someone
and like having it like be a conversation
and the food is like a compliment to that
because it's a shared
experience, that you can discuss.
And if you don't know,
someone's like, oh, okay,
well maybe you can talk about the food
and then it opens you up a little bit.
I don't know.
I just really like that aspect of it.
And I don't like that being
like ruined like people
trying to like monetize it
- Right in front of your salad.
- Right, I'm just trying to
enjoy my immaculate meal,
my A5 beef.
- My my immaculate salad.
- And sometimes I'll post a picture.
Oh no, sorry, I'll take a picture.
99% of the time I don't post.
It's just for me.
I'm like, I want to remember this.
- That's something I've noticed recently.
I'd say, especially in the
last like two or three years
or so, where I've, for some reason
the more I do social media
and the more I used to post,
now I post way less.
I experience more, if that makes sense.
- This is like a lot of people ask,
Garnt, why don't you post on Instagram?
Garnt, post more on Instagram
- I fucking don't post
anything on Instagram too.
- I remember I've tried so many times
to get more my Instagram.
And that's just because I fucking
hate having an experience.
This is the thing I hate the most
having some kind of experience
whether it's a nice meal or
you're going somewhere new.
I feel pressured to document it.
- Yeah.
- Like I got to take a nice
photo of this for Instagram.
- Like for one, I fucking
suck at taking photos.
- Oh yeah.
- So half the time I'm
like trying to figure out,
how do I make what I see look good?
(Joey laughs)
Like, how do I do that?
This is why I don't work
with like live action stuff.
But I also, I just hate that experience
of just having to feel like
I need to document this.
I need to make sure the
world knows what I'm doing.
And I feel like ever since
I just completely given up
on my Instagram.
Yes, I've just given up at this point.
- Everybody unfollow now.
- You can unfollow me,
I probably won't notice.
But like, as soon as I just gave up on it,
then it just felt like a
weight was off my shoulder.
- Right
- And I feel like Twitter for
me is just way more casual.
- I love Twitter.
- I love Twitter, yeah.
- Twitter, I don't have to try.
It's just, I say any stupid
story that comes to my mind.
- Dude, I tweeted penis
and it got 25,000 likes.
I'm like, you guys will
like fucking anything.
But like with Instagram, yeah.
I'm kind of the same.
Like, I'm pretty I'm not gonna
say I'm active on Instagram,
- You're like the most active of us.
- I'm probably the most
active but the thing is,
is that like, I'd say
the past 10 to 15 photos
I put up on Instagram, I didn't take.
It was either Aki took
it, or somebody else,
like Luke took a lot of recent ones.
Cause he's a camera guy.
- I just never think when
I'm at a place I'm like,
I should take a picture,
like I do occasionally,
there's pictures of my
Instagram at places.
But most of the time I never
think I should take a picture.
I'm like, I'm just gonna enjoy it.
Like, I don't know.
Yeah, and that shouldn't
be like a thing of like,
wow, look how amazing I am.
I just...
- You have nothing to prove, right?
It's like, I don't have to
take a nice photo of this trip
I went to.
To prove to you that, oh,
I went on this nice trip.
Like that should just be
something that you should cherish,
not to say, don't post your
experiences on Instagram.
Like if, if you're okay
with that, go for it, right?
- Yeah.
- But it's not a necessity,
especially if you're a
content creator or YouTuber.
- I think what we're saying, more like,
Dolby is about other content
creators or other YouTubers.
Because as a content creator
you do commodify your life
and you need to find as I
learned that I needed to find
some parts of my life that just
weren't touched by YouTube.
- Yeah, really have to
like actively make sure
you're thinking about it.
- I also think that
when you're starting out
it's a lot easier to fall into
the traps of self-employed.
Cause a lot of the time
YouTubers are young.
And, you know, I started when I was 19.
And I have no chill.
- You were 19 when you started?
- Yeah, 19 when I started.
- How old were you when you started Garnt?
- 17.
- 17, I was 18 when I started.
- I find when you get
that first initial growth
your thought is to pour
everything into it.
- Yeah.
- I definitely did do that
and I definitely got
burned out very quickly.
Cause I was doing university
as well at the time.
- Yeah, same.
- So it was like, I was putting in
a full 40 hour work week on my YouTube.
And then I was putting probably
not a full 40 hour work week
into my university studies.
- Oh no, it was definitely
like YouTube, university.
- Yeah.
- And then my social life was just,
- In sham
- you know, tumbleweed.
Yeah, and the sad thing is
that for every one of us
that you hear the success story.
there's a lot of survivor
bias with that kind of stuff.
Because for every three,
YouTubers like, that did it,
during a job or university,
we made it through,
but it was probably like a hundred people
who sweat their ass off
full throughout university
to get into work and failed miserably,
didn't have anything to show for it.
Like I took a gamble and it worked off
but it was a dumb gamble in reality.
- Yeah.
- But I was passionate about it.
- But I mean the more dumb
gamble for you would have been
if you saw that little bit
of success and you're like,
I'm going to quit university.
- Which is something
that you should never do.
- So yeah, please do that.
Cause I was going to do a
master's, but I ended up
getting a bachelor's because
I just hated engineering
by the end of it, I got
a two, one at the end.
So I was like, I'll take
it, its good enough.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Do you have that in US?
- What?
- Like the rating system.
- I mean, I'm not from the U S.
- Is there like different
levels of degree?
- Like, yeah.
- Like bachelor's, master's.
- Not the bachelor's like the
pass rate like the floors.
- Oh.
- First, two, one, two, two.
- I don't know, I only..
- Like first, second or third degree.
- I probably got the lowest one.
I legitimately just slid past.
I was like, give me the
paper, I'm fucking out.
- Gotta go to fucking first baby.
- Oh my God, dude.
- You shouldn't, you would,
I wish Garnt was in my
dissertation presentation.
You wouldn't have
fucking cackled this way.
(Garnt laughs)
So I'll go on a tangent real quick.
So my dissertation was fucking awful.
A dissertation, by the
way, is your final paper.
It's like 30 pages long.
And in my one in
engineering, we have to like
actually either prove something
like that's been proved
before or like make a device or something.
So I decided I'm gonna make,
so we were given a topic
and my topic,
- You told me this.
- my topic was a wave energy device.
I loved renewable energies
and I loved doing that.
And luckily we had like one
of the best guys in the UK,
it was the guy who was my tutor.
- Right.
- So I was like, yeah dude, I
can make a wave energy device.
Wave energy devices have never been proven
to like work very well.
In concept they work but they
don't work in large scales.
- Right, right.
- Normally it's below the waves.
- Yeah.
- Like the flow of the bumblebees.
So I was like, but I can do it.
I can make a device that will work.
I had like no experience in work-shopping
or like making things.
So I didn't know why I
thought this would go well.
So I did this whole paper.
I wrote this, everything
about it, about this concept
then I had to build the concept.
And it was the biggest piece of shit
I ever built in my life.
So I dead ass, made this like
pathetic little wooden thing
with some copper coils strapped to it
then like a bobbing thing,
I got like a toilet float.
I turned up to this thing, like a kid,
like a six year old kid.
- At the science fair, right?
- At the science fair,
it was literally science
fair quality, but even worse than that,
and I turn up and I'm like,
so I go through 10 minutes
of all this very detailed,
scientific, like calculations,
the proofing and then I
pull out this piece of shit,
cardboard thing, like wooden plywood.
And I'm like, so you just
pull this up and down
with the waves and it'll make electricity.
And then I had an LED
attached, one singular LED
and he's like, that's not powering it.
And I'm like, you have to go really fast.
So I start doing like
this like fucking this,
like jacking it off basically.
And he's like, so do you know
any waves that go that fast?
And I was like, no, there are
no waves that go that fast.
- I love that's like the
most university professor
kind of question.
It's like they will ask you questions
where they know the answer.
They just want to see you like,
bullshit your way through this.
- Yeah, there's two people, my tutor.
And he was giggling the whole
time when I pulled it out.
And the auditor kind of person
who does the scene before
and I had to dead ass and look
her in the eye and be like,
this is very scientific, very accurate.
It will work, I promise.
This is so embarrassing,
and everyone before me
was in a full suit and I
just turned up in a T-shirt.
I did know that we had to dress nice.
And so it was just fucking painful.
And then he kept asking me questions like,
can you hook it up to a battery?
And I'm like, I don't have
any dry cells lying around.
Maybe you do.
I don't really know.
(laughing)
- You got any lithium material cell?
- What did you do? you just made a device
to light an LED that didn't even do that.
- And so I basically made a very basic
electromagnetic thing.
- That's what it sounded like.
- Just like you put the magnet in a coil
and then it makes electricity.
- Yeah, so the idea was that
it bobs up with the wave.
- Flemmings left hand rule.
- It's like some shit people
were doing in like the 1600s
for science experiments.
- The problem is is that
there's too many variables in waves.
Like yeah, you would need like hundreds
of the little wave devices.
But how the fuck are
you going to have that
on top of the waves?
The shit's going to break all the time.
Basically, it doesn't work.
I fucked up and I embarrassed myself.
- I just remembered a similar thing for...
It wasn't for like, cause
we didn't really have
like a dissertation for us.
We had like three big
projects that we had to do.
And then those three
projects would go on display
at like the graduation
party for our curriculum.
And one of them for the
course that I was doing was...
I did like a computer robotics course.
And have you ever seen like those robots?
They have them a lot in
America, but they're those
like robot arms that are
basically like robot bartenders.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- I think it's an Australian
invention, but basically
it's just this giant white
arm that's programmable
and it pulls drinks basically.
It's just an automated cartoon robot.
So we had one of those
because I think our university
was the first to develop it or something
and we had one laying around.
So we had to make a program
that used the bartender robot
and then they would show that
off at the graduation party
to actually serve drinks
at the graduation party.
So I'm like, okay, that sounds dope.
The problem was is that
it was a group project.
Never goes well.
And second of all,
I was the only one who
knew how to program.
(Garnt laughs)
And third of all, I sucked at programming.
So we made this like whole thing.
We planned out this giant
thing being like, all right,
let's do it where when you press
this button, you can choose
like the amount of shots
that can go into the glass.
You can choose the glass
size, all this shit.
And we're like, all right,
who's going to program it.
The other two looked
at me and they're like,
we don't know how to program.
I was like, all right, I
guess I'm programming it.
- It's always that point where you're like
does anyone not know how to do this?
Fuck, I'm going to take responsibility.
- He's like, all right, I guess
I have to learn JavaScript
from scratch man, sick and C++.
Okay, yeah, I can do this.
- Is that working?
- And so in the end we have to present it.
Kind of like at this
stage we have to present
in front of the class, but the problem was
the only thing that worked.
There was one thing that worked.
We had like 10 different options
that you could choose from.
None of them work, except for one.
And that was the one
where you press a button
and it'll pour a beer.
(Garnt laughing)
A single beer.
- That's the most Australian
thing I've heard all day.
- Australia has been saved.
- Not even like, and this is a button
you could only press once.
Once the robot poured
one beer, that was it.
The app was dead.
- Oh my God.
- We passed, somehow.
I don't fucking know.
But then the professor was like,
so do you want to have this
on the graduation thing?
We're just like, no, no, please.
I'm not even going to
show up to the graduation.
I'm too embarrassed
because I'm going to see all
these other amazing projects
and just feel like absolute shit for it.
But if you want one beer, it's all yours.
- It'd better be the
best beer of your life.
- It was like some VB shit.
- Oh God, fuck.
- You guys have reminded
me of like so many
of my university projects
and dissertations.
Like I remember my
dissertation was like a lot.
Did your dissertation feel
like a lifetime to complete?
Because mine did.
And I remember like weather
station, had several stages.
I remember like,
- Depression,
- like one of the first
stages I had to build
like a wireless antenna.
So we had to like, had to build a system
where I could transfer data wirelessly.
And my friend actually helped me build it.
And I remember we basically just recreated
probably the invention of porn.
Right? (Joey laughs)
Okay, because what happens?
We were working on this
for like an entire day
and we couldn't get it working.
We were like, why is
this not transmitting?
Is this the receiver, maybe
receiving the signals wrong.
We don't know, and then suddenly,
after so much work, we'd
like, get it working.
We send like this
message like, hello world
or some basic ass message.
And it was just like the
fucking Eureka moment.
It was like such a bro moment.
That was like, yes, we
got this message to send.
We got data from one antenna
to another wirelessly.
And then we just looked at each other.
We're like, what do we do now?
And he could just go, let's
try sending ASCII porn.
- So mute on the real
porn, just ASCII porn.
- No, we couldn't send that
much data at that time.
So we were just like, what can we send?
Let's send ASCII boobies.
So we Googled like a naked girl with like,
through an ASCII filter.
And then we try sending
that and we're like,
yeah, it fucking works.
- And thus porn was invented?
- And we're in the room like, wait,
this is exactly how porn was started.
Just imagine some scientists
having this Eureka moment,
getting like, imagine like
the telegram being invented.
And then the next thing they want to send
is fucking ASCII porn
or something like that.
- I don't remember that in history.
- I was like, we could go to the store
to buy the Playboy magazine
or you could just send
it to me while I'm home.
- He was like, Ooh.
- Jacking off to ASCII boobies, okay.
- Exactly, but like I remember,
I remember going all the way forward
to when I had to present it.
And I'm like, I'm still
fucking pissed to this day.
Cause I had my project, which
I worked so fucking hard on.
I actually knew, it was actually working.
It was like
- Why do you gotta do me like that?
- Wow, the call out.
- Wow.
- It was many sleepless
nights, many red bulls
to get this fucking
tracking system working
that I had been working on all year.
And so for some reason, you know,
like that dickhead professor
just seems to wake up
and he just wants to be an asshole.
He just, for some reason
that was the day he woke up
and he wants to be an asshole.
So he just starts grilling
me on this presentation
on my presentation and asking me questions
that you shouldn't expect
from my level basically.
I mean, I was doing a masters
but he was asking me
like PhD level questions.
I don't know why.
And I was there for a
good, like 20 minutes.
- Why do you hate me?
- Because I swear the questioning
was meant to be like 10 minutes, max.
He's going to ask you 10
minutes worth of questions.
He goes on for 20 minutes.
And I'm like sweating.
It was like the worst job
interview I've ever been in.
Like, you know, when you're
just spitting bullshit
and you don't even know
if it's correct anymore.
That was like the point I was getting at.
So, he finishes with me and
I'm just like,(Garnt gasps)
what the? why did he do that to me?
I'm like sweating.
I didn't even get a good
mark off my presentation
but what really kills me is
that the person next to me
was the one girl in my class.
The one girl in an engineering class.
- He didn't grill her?
- And okay, so I saw his face.
So like when he was like, grilling me,
he was like eyebrows frowned,
like, yeah, whatever.
I don't give a shit about what you said.
Goes up to the next person.
Hi, what project do you have here?
- My boy's horny on me.
(Garnt laughing)
- And I know, I know for a
fact that she didn't know
that that thing didn't fucking work.
She didn't put any fucking work into it.
But she got a higher mark
on the presentation than me
and my thing actually worked.
Fuck you.
- And it's like, well, now we know
who is sucking the
professor off after class.
- I don't know how we got this present.
I don't know how we got this fucking time.
- Yeah, back to the YouTube burnout.
I was telling the story and like,
I think the most burnout
I ever got on YouTube,
like cause we can get
into like now later on.
But I remember, when I
first moved to London
for some reason, cause
I was going to London
quite a lot to do voice work.
So I was like, fuck it.
I'll just move there
because why not?
There's nothing better to do.
And I moved there and I was
making about 1200 a month total
before tax, which, not great.
- So you're making about $500.
- Well, yeah, and my rent
was like 600 pounds a month.
Council tax was like a
hundred pounds a month.
And then there was bills included.
So well, after all bills and tax was gone,
I was left with like
a hundred to 200 bucks
for like food and stuff.
And I was like, oh, oh, that's not good.
That's not good, and then...
- Do the math.
- Yeah, I was doing the
math on my spreadsheet
and it was like, you're fucked,
you're absolutely fucked.
And so...
- That's put in a spreadsheet formula,
it comes out, you're fucked.
- Conclusion, you're fucked.
- So that first month I
moved there, I was like,
I really wanted to change
my content up as well
because I was doing strictly
like Black Butler based stuff
at the time.
And I was desperate to get out of that
because I really didn't want
to keep doing that because I..
- You were burned out at Black Butler.
- I'd fucking started hating it.
And the viewers were really
obnoxious at times as well.
And so I really wanted to
make this content work.
And as you guys know, when you...
Normally when you try
new stuff on YouTube,
the first few times you do
it, it isn't perceived well.
Normally people are a
bit hesitant about it.
At least, it was quite drastic
at the time, for me at least.
So I started doing new content
and I was working my ass off
and none of it was getting views.
And I was like, oh, I'm gonna go broke.
I'm not going to be able to...
- I'm in danger.
- I'm like Chuckles,
I'm like, yo, these next
four videos, bangers,
hundred percent bangers.
- Yeah, yeah.
- This is my new content, new me.
This is where I'm going
to turn it all around.
Then they all bombed so hard.
- Like how hard are we talking?
- I was averaging about,
in 24 hours I was averaging
about 25 K views at that time up to 30
which is not...
- How many subs did you have at the time?
When I moved to London, it
must've been about 200 K.
- Okay, okay.
- I think I was averaging
anywhere between 25 K
to 50 K views, a video
a week, which is fine.
- Yeah.
- And I remember these videos all came out
and they got like eight K.
- Oh.
- I checked the address
and it was like $15.
And I was like, I'm getting $15 a month
from these videos, I'm going
to go fucking broke man.
And then fucking Amino
come down and being like,
hey, you want $200 for a sponsored video.
I have like, no fucking
choice, but to take it.
Cause I'm actually gonna like be homeless
If I don't take it or I'm
gonna have to ask my mom
for like, hey mom, can you spot me?
I don't want to do that.
I don't ask my parents for money.
- I love how Amino's
every man's first sponsor.
- Because they fucking rip you off.
- Yeah, I remember they
were my first sponsor.
- They know how to slide in well.
- Cause their whole tactic
is going after channels
that have like, are up and coming,
that don't know any better.
Because I know they gave people
who gave them a million
view videos 15 bucks.
- Yep.
- What?
- 15 bucks, because they
don't know any better.
It's crazy.
- What?
- And genius.
- It's just genius but slimy as fuck.
- Completely slimy, 100 genius.
- And yeah.
And then luckily, you
know, those videos later on
started turning over
all around maybe three
or four months later and it started
to really pick up the new stuff.
I started getting an audience, but man,
those three months where
it wasn't picking up
were the scariest for
three months of my life.
Cause I thought I was going
to like, I mean, okay,
I've never tried super
fucking hard at something
in my life and failed.
I thought like, fuck.
- I'm a winner.
- Cause I'm, I'm psychotic
when I want to get something done.
Like I was working like,...
- I think stoic is the
word you're looking for.
- Psychotic.
(laughing)
- You are past stoic
- I was like a relationship vlogger bro.
I was on full psychopath mode bro.
I was working easily,
like 12, 14 hours a day.
To get this shit working.
I didn't have any time for video games.
Cause I was like, I
need to make this work.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And it wasn't working.
And I'm like, what am I doing wrong?
And then it was probably cause
I was probably too invested
in it probably didn't help.
Because I felt that every
single video I was going
to make could make me
homeless if I fucked it up.
So it was like, fuck, not
am I overly invested in this
because I really want it to succeed.
I'm also going to go fucking homeless.
If I don't get this fucking working.
And it's like, you see it.
I see it with streamers as well.
When they're like, I'm
gonna stream 12 hours a day.
And I'm like, that is...
- Bro, I don't know how
streamers do it man.
Streamers is a skillset that
I could never understand
that I could never do no
matter how much I try.
- I think it's your personality though,
because I think if it was my job,
I think I'd have no problem
streaming it eight hours a day.
- I would have massive problems.
- I don't think I'd have, I
just want to do other shit.
Like I could do it, but I'd
prefer to do other shit.
- I very quickly noticed like,
we talked about last week
about how I've been getting
into VTuber streams and whatnot.
And I have a lot of like IRL
stream of friends as well.
Like, some of them can go
like eight to 12 hours a day.
No problems at all.
I've noticed that like,
with streaming, it really is
like YouTube, where anybody can start it
but not anybody can do it.
- Yeah.
- You really have to be built.
- It takes years of fucking up.
- It does.
- And also the right personality.
- Yeah, because people come into YouTube
thinking they can succeed right away.
And what they don't, like
YouTube is not about making
one bang of videos.
The way I see YouTube is that
if you make enough videos,
eventually, eventually,
you're going to get one
that's on the algorithm.
And I've seen so many channels
that are just have like,
have like a thousand views on every video.
And then one view, one
video gets like 200, 300
sometimes a million views.
And you just can't recreate that.
And it's about being able to
consistently grow your views.
It's not about getting
that one bang of video.
It's about slowly, like some
people rise up very quickly,
but you shouldn't ever think
that you're gonna be one
of those people, those
are like the lucky ones.
But I believe that if
you play your cards right
and if you know what you're
doing in terms of marketing
on YouTube, there is a
path that you can take
that is sustainable growth.
- Yeah, YouTube to me, isn't
about getting 15 minutes
of fame and then you've made it.
It's about getting 15 minutes of fame
every day, consistently.
- It's about making 10
videos that are good
and are growing consistently,
and never stopping.
And that's why burnout exists,
it's because once you've
finished one video
you have like a day of
rest and you realize
you got to do it all over again.
- No matter how good the last
one was, it doesn't matter
because that's not going to be like,
you're not a movie actor.
- That's not going to pay your
bills for the next ten years.
- Yeah, unfortunately.
- Okay, do you guys
remember an exact point
when you just kind of
realized, like, you know
when you started YouTube, you're like,
I can do this forever.
Making videos, talking
about anime, fucking easy.
This is like the dream
job, I can do this forever.
Do you ever have a point
when you're just like, man,
what's the end game of this?
Like, what am I doing?
- You know, when I worked at McDonald's,
I didn't think like, what's
the end game to this.
(Joey laughing)
I mean, how many McFlurries
do I got to make?
- But like, did you ever
think, man, how much longer
can I keep just making McFlurries?
(Connor laughs)
- What is there off the shop manager?
What's above that?
- Dude, the moment I started
working at McDonald's.
I was like, I want to
leave here so fucking bad
but I really want that new X-Box
but I really wanna fucking leave.
- Well, that's the end game, right?
That's the goal that is an end game
- X-Box is the end game.
- I guess.
It's hard because I think what I want
out of YouTube changes constantly.
- Yeah.
- I think right now I'm
in a place where I think
I'm the best way I've
ever been on YouTube.
I think I've got my mental
health at the best place
where it's ever been on YouTube.
I really do separate.
And I really do take care
of myself, which is weird.
Cause I got a comment on a
few recent videos that like,
is Connor doing okay?
- There's always those comments.
- Is Connor depressed?
- Yeah, and it's weird.
Cause like if I am more real
in the videos, if anything,
I've stopped caring about
if I look kind of annoyed
or depressed at any points.
Like maybe when I'm directing someone
or doing something like that.
- You don't have to bother
with like the business smile.
- No, I just turn on the camera
and just literally just do me.
And I feel like it's being
received better than ever.
And it's hard to do that, but also I think
because I've gotten such a good
control over the separation
of job and like, what I'm doing?
Like, when I went away
this weekend, Niigata,
I didn't think about
YouTube for one moment
for like four days.
I upload a video at one point,
but that's just one point
in the evening where I
schedule it, and that's it.
Like, I just don't think about YouTube
when I'm not working now.
And how I managed to do
that, because I remember
there was a time when,
like I said in London,
I could not turn it off.
Like I could not stop
thinking about YouTube.
Everything was YouTube.
Like, what am I gonna do next?
What's the new idea?
What's this new deal?
- Cause I remember you messaged
me a couple of days ago
when you were still up in Niigata.
And we had like a really
brief discussion about it
about how Connor was like,
is it bad that I'm starting
to care less about YouTube?
Not in the sense of like,
I don't care about videos
but it doesn't take over my life as much.
- Yeah, I will get back
to your question later,
but I guess, cause it's weird.
Because my whole YouTube
career, if you will,
I've always thought about it.
- Yeah.
- Always like I don't
stop thinking about it.
And I'm like, is it bad
that I have large periods
of time like, two, three days
where I can just not think about it?
Is that bad?
Like, I don't know.
Am I bad?
- No, no.
That's like yours, that's healthy.
That's what I'm trying to do.
I haven't been able to achieve that.
- Right.
- I think throughout my YouTube career.
- Really?
- I think that's my problem.
I think like...
- I wish I could tell you how I did it.
(Connor laughs)
- This year, especially, I
think I've been like close
to burnout around like fucking 10 times.
- You've been really bad this year.
- And I think it's just because this year.
- Fuck you Connor.
- You suck this year.
- Fuck you guys.
- I think I can definitely
tell when around you
that you're like...
I can feel that you're stressed about it.
- And I think just because normally
I'm used to a change of environment
or change of breath room
just because of like the global situation.
We've not been able to travel.
- Lockdown has definitely made it worse.
- Lockdown has just made
it like 10 times worse.
And I know, like I've gotten
a few comments recently, like,
Oh, Garnt's uploading videos
less, what's going on there?
And I was like, there's nothing going on.
I'm just staring at a blank.
That's the problem.
The thing that really
stresses me out is this notion
that if you don't upload
like in the viewers mind,
if you don't upload
- You're dead.
- Everyone's thinking
either he's dead or man,
he must be working on a banger video.
(Joey laughing)
He must be pooling all his time
to this fucking banger video.
And it's just, sometimes that
just makes it more pressure.
Like, especially if there's
a long break that, man,
coming back with just
another of the same upload
I've been doing before just
makes it really difficult.
- That's one thing that I
guess is like the good thing
about having a schedule or like good thing
about having a timeframe of like,
okay, it's been however many
days, I have to upload a video.
Because that expectation
gets completely thrown out the window.
And then when you do release
that banger of a video,
it's a pleasant surprise, right?
You're like, oh, shit, my
man was able to do this
in the same timeframe as a regular video.
All right, I see you.
- I know it's an unhealthy mindset
but sometimes even when I'm on holiday
or even when I'm like away,
I'm secretly thinking to myself like,
hmm, this could have
been time that I've used,
was doing something on my channel.
- That's like a big no in my mind.
- When I go on vacation.
- I don't know how to switch
off though, I really don't.
- I guess.
Having like a little bit of
backlog of videos is like,
you see what you don't have.
- That's it, that's it.
Because I have never in
my YouTube career felt
like I've been on top of my
work, because unlike you guys,
I finish a video, I upload it.
And that grace period, that
20 to 48 hour grace period
after I upload a video, that's my holiday.
Because that's the only
time I can mentally be like,
okay, I deserve this break.
- I feel uncomfortable
if I'm not at least four
or five videos recorded ahead.
Like, they may not be edited and done.
But like, I don't feel comfortable
unless I have that buffer.
Because like, for example, when
I moved back to my parents,
before moving to Japan, I
just wasn't in the mood.
Because I hated the environment.
I love my parents, but I
just didn't like being home.
And I just didn't want to make videos.
So I just didn't.
And then also when I moved to Japan,
I wanted to enjoy Japan
for the first month.
So I didn't do videos for a month.
I didn't feel bad about that,
because I had the backlog
and I completely used all of
my backlog for that month.
And also I just don't have to worry
about taking a weekend off or taking off.
I haven't made a video
or done any video stuff
in about a week and a half now.
I don't know why, I just can't
think of ideas right now.
And I've also been really fucking busy.
I mean, we did the, oh, the video
that we can't talk about yet.
That's coming out soon.
- We did a special thing.
- We did a special video.
And then also we have the
podcast in between there
and then I've been really
busy and I was way behind
on a bunch of other stuff.
So it's just like having
that backlog, even if,
okay, this is my advice to your Garnt.
Even if you have to do a
month between each upload,
try and get like one or two videos backlog
that you can like drip out
so that you can at least
then take those one or
two days off and be like,
I'm not going to think about
it, because I don't need to.
I'm going to take these days off.
I know I'm taking these days off.
So why would I ruin them
by thinking about like,
Oh, shit, what are the
Fiverr sellers up to?
What are they doing?
What pawn are they drawing?
You know what I mean?
Like I dunno.
I really, it's difficult.
I guess I fucked it up so many
times that I've learned now.
- I feel like I'm on
like the extreme of that
because, say for example, like, you know,
every AX which is in July,
- Fuck.
I usually go to America for like.
- Makes me sad remembering that.
I usually go to America
from anywhere between one
to three months because I'm going around,
I'm visiting places, whatnot.
And so I have to make a backlog.
I mean, I could technically
just make videos
while I'm at Aki's parents' place,
but that would be fucking weird.
And I don't want to use my time on holiday
because it takes
technically the whole night
to fucking worry about work.
So, two months before that I just grind.
I grind like fucking crazy.
And I make like legit two to three months
worth of videos ahead.
I don't know how I do it.
- That's like something
I have never heard of.
- Dude, last year I made 12 videos ahead.
- I wish, I wish I could
be that ahead, man.
I wish, I like wake up and
I dream of that moment.
- And it was great because
for those one to three months
that I was away, because
we also went to like Europe
and stuff and like, I went to go see you.
And I went to go see everyone,
all my friends in Europe
and all my friends in America.
The thought of YouTube
was just completely gone.
I turned back into just
regular Joey for two months.
And it was so liberating, but
it's a double-edged sword.
Because when you're not
thinking about your job
or doing YouTube for that
long, and you come back to it,
it's like taking a gap year at uni.
- It is a little difficult
to get back into it.
But you also might come into
it more refreshed than ever.
- Oh, no, yeah. that's what I mean.
That's why it's a double-edged sword
because it can easily be
either one of the two.
You can either come back and be like,
I have like 20 new ideas.
Or you can come back and be
like fuck I don't wanna do this.
- I think the point that was
the biggest turning point
for me was getting an editor.
- Oh yes.
- And I know that you always think that
like YouTube was always like, man
but I've just got this touch to it.
And I'm like, no, you're fucking wrong.
You are actually just wrong.
There was someone who could do it better
than you because that's
their job, to just do that.
- They can do it better and faster
- Better, faster and guess what?
- You've free time now,
you know what that's like,
you never had that before.
And I sucked at editing.
I fucking sucked, Garnt edits.
- I mean Garnt told me to...
- I convinced Joey to get an editor.
- Yeah, because up until
less than two years ago,
I was editing all my videos.
- I remember back in the
early days of YouTube
people used to be iffy
about, like viewers used
to get like pissed if you had an editor.
- Yeah.
- But not anymore, I'm
glad that it's changed.
- Yeah, that's like sponsorships, right?
It's just grown to be like accepting.
- The way I see it is that
I've gotten better editing.
And now I have more time
to make better videos
and I can make more ambitious videos
because I'm not the one.
Cause the worst thing was, is that like,
I want to make this video ambitious
but don't add more work
in post for myself.
So it was always like, you
would always limit yourself
because you're like, I don't
want to have to add work.
- This is my problem.
Because apparently I'm
a fucking workaholic.
- You are a workaholic.
- It's just, I dunno, like
I just want to feel ahead
of my work for once in my life.
And it's really hard because I don't know.
- You're too hands-on.
- Yeah, I am too hands-on but even like,
even if I have an editor.
I need to learn how to just
see what the viewer sees.
Because every time I get an edit,
so every time I come up
with a finished video
I can always be like,
I can make this better.
I can improve this by an extra little bit.
And I always end up doing it.
- Guess that's the bad thing
about being a perfectionist.
It's that like, you'll never satisfied.
- I mean, you could argue that.
Yeah, Maybe that extra touch
you do put in is the reason
why you've done so well.
You know, why everyone comes
to watch your videos on anime
Maybe it is, maybe it
wouldn't matter at all.
- Yeah, I dunno.
This is just like my...
- Why don't you test though?
Why don't you do a test?
- Test it out, just let Allan
just take all of the editing.
- Cause they will fucking kill me.
(laughing)
- But this is the thing,
you've got to let go,
you've got to let go.
- Here is the thing bro,
because it's not just about one video.
As we know, you can't get enough metrics
or enough analytics of one video.
- That's true.
- Like you can make what
you feel is like the worst
fucking video of your channel
and for some reason it does well.
- What if you put it out there
and it's, nothing happened.
Oh, shit, I can just let him do it.
- Because the exact
opposite happened with me.
When you talked me into
hiring Mudan to be my editor,
I was like, okay.
Mudan watches my videos,
so he should have a good grasp of it.
All right, I'll let him edit
like the first couple of videos.
Dude, the first couple of videos,
I feel so bad towards Mudan,
cause I made him redo that
first video like five times.
Cause I was like, all right,
add this little zoom in here.
No, I would have added this here.
I would have added this here
and I feel so bad now Mudan.
But nowadays I can just
be like, all right, Mudan.
Here's the script, here's
the raw files, go ham fam.
And he always just nails it.
- I think one of the biggest things
that an editor does as well.
At least for our kind of
content is that, dude,
I do so much embarrassing shit,
that I would delete for sure.
- Oh yeah.
- That would never make it into the cut,
that they would put in.
And the first time I saw it, I'm like,
I don't really like that.
I look kind of fucking stupid there.
And then after a while I'm like,
I guess that's kind of funny
and adds a bit of charms.
So now if I ever work with
anyone who edits my videos,
I'm like, please make me
look as stupid as fuck.
Make me look so fucking dumb.
Please poke fun at me the whole time.
- The whole monkey brain.
- Yeah, poke fun of me.
Cause like, I mean that's, what's funny.
And now I find that funny.
- Yeah, it's very British self-doubt.
- Very much, yeah.
- But I also like now,
cause I work with multiple editors now.
So like I always just tell them
now to just throw in as much
of your personality into your
editing, as best as possible.
Because I feel that like the
landscape of YouTube editors
has kind of changed in the
sense that now YouTube editors
have almost become their
own identity in the video
where like, perfect example
is Game Grumps, for example.
Like Barry, the first
editor was just as much
of an important aspect of
Game Grumps as the hosts were.
And I feel that like with a
lot of YouTubers the editor
is kind of just become another part
of that person's like personality.
I feel it just clearly makes
for a different type of video
but also it makes it really
unique at the same time.
- I guess that's why I'm having
such a hard time letting go
because I feel like what I
do is I put my personality
into like I let Allen do the
hard, like most of the work
and like the other 5% is just me.
Like, I'm self inserting
myself into my videos,
but I feel like it's because of that
that people would know me
or like why sit down in the first place?
It's because my videos are very personal
and it's like my personality reflected.
Not only in like my script,
but my editing as well.
And the way, like I edit jokes.
- You and Alan have known
each other for so long.
- Oh yeah.
- I feel like Alan would have a good grasp
of your type of personality.
- He definitely does.
There are some videos that take
no effort at all for him to edit.
And there's some videos
where he's just like
I don't know what the fuck.
I dunno, it's a difficult balance.
I'm still working on it.
It's funny that I'm like 13 years
into my YouTube career or whatever.
- Still haven't figured this shit out.
- Yeah, I still haven't
figured this shit out.
It's only because me and Connor
were talking about like
our perfect vacation.
And like our perfect
vacation, which we were like,
we were hoping to do sometime
after COVID allowed us.
Was just like fly to
Korea, spend an entire day
in like a gaming cafe.
- Multiple days.
- Or multiple days and just
playing league of legends.
And if you would play league
of legends, Joey, we'd be like,
let's get Joey on board.
- Oh my God, but the only
problem with that is I have
to play league of legends.
(laughing)
- It's good fun, it's good fun.
It's to me, like the perfect
vacation is just shutting off.
And like I miss being able to
waste all day playing games
and what better way to do it
than in Korea in a gaming cafe
with like, where you can
get food, all that kind
of shit delivered to your table.
- Oh, it sounds amazing.
- Yeah, I really want to,
I love league and I...
- I'll join you guys,
but I'll play Mario 64.
- Yeah, you can come and
just chill next to us
on one of the PC, play PUBG, I don't know.
What do you play on PC Joey?
- I dunno, I was just going
to fuck you or something.
(laughing)
- You be like, do you
guys wanna go outside?
- I'm just imagining that,
but we can also go out
and get fucking Korean
barbecue, some amazing food.
And I'm just like, this is
just the perfect holiday.
Fuck traveling, fuck seeing things.
- I'm the kind of guy
when I go on vacation.
I just, because I work so fucking much.
The last thing I want to
do is work on my vacation
in terms of like doing too much shit.
Like I just want to eat
food, drink and relax
and like take it easy.
Like, I like beaches, but
I mean, I normally just,
I like good hotels as well.
- I mean that's why like,
whenever I go on a vacation
with Aki or I go on a
vacation with like my friends,
I usually let them decide.
And I just kind of tag along and be like,
I'm down for anything now.
If we want to go sightseeing, cool.
If we want to just drink, cool.
- Yeah.
- I'm very hands-off with my vacation.
If there's a schedule I'm like, no, no.
This is already a turnoff right now.
- Oh, should love food.
- Where are some places though
that we've been thinking
to go once COVID is over?
I mean, we mentioned Korea, right?
- Yeah, I would like to go to Korea
to just spend some few days.
- Is that like at the top of
your bucket list right now?
- I mean right now cause
it's just easiest to get to.
- It's like less than
an hour by plane, right?
- Yeah, and I remember going
to Korea like two years ago.
- I've never been.
- I've never been either.
- Actually like Seoul's
just very much like Tokyo,
just less busy.
And I very much enjoyed the vibe
and also the e-sports
scene was massive there.
I went there for the league
of legends, grand finals.
- We both love watching
the legends worlds.
- Yeah, that's starting soon,
but yeah, I flew all the way
to Korea just to see Fanatic get decimated
but the experience was
fucking fantastic man.
Like the team, I was actually
cheering for got destroyed,
but just going there and
seeing this massive stadium
like the noise that they
made, like I've been
to a football match before,
but I still think the energy
of this like stadium
watching a fucking video game
was like 10 times more intense.
- Oh yeah.
I mean like I've seen clips
of sports commentators
versus e-sports commentators.
- Pentakill.
- Pentakill, Pentakill.
- I love that clip.
- I love that clip because
I'm just like, wow,
this guy is excited about Pentakill.
- There's so many good clips like that.
The commentators get so hyped
It's great, I love it.
- I mean, I totally get it though, right?
- Dude, we get so fucking
hyped when we watch it, dude.
We would like, stand
up like, what the fuck?
- I mean, we get worked up,
whenever we watched like insane speed runs
We're just like, what's happening.
- That's the true spectator's full.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Did Super Monkey Ball speed runs,
the best thing to watch dude.
- It's like the cocaine of speed run
- Dude, if you get super drunk
and watch super monkey ball speed runs.
It's so fun.
- Which is what we did last Christmas.
- We just got massively drunk
and watched Super Monkey Ball speed run.
- It was so fun because you're like,
what is happening?
- How do you practice this?
- You're like, what the fuck?
Then the next course starts
and, what's he going to do?
Then he fucking flips the whole world
and gets it in across the map.
And you're like, what the fuck
It's so good.
- What is it about motion
controls that makes it
so much more impressive.
- It's just crazy.
Man, going back to YouTube burnout.
- Yeah.
- Well, where were we on that point?
- I mean, is there anything
else we want to talk about?
- I wonder, like where
are you right now with it,
like, do you feel, would
you say you're burnout?
- I was in like kind of a mini burnout.
- I feel like I just have
artist's block right now,
I cannot think of anything.
I don't dislike it, I
love it more than ever,
I just can't think of anything now.
- I think speaking, honestly,
I'm like pretty close to burnout.
Yeah, it's been difficult
because I was already
having trouble keeping up and
a semblance of like a schedule
this year and then Trash Taste started.
And like, you think, cause
we take one day off a week
to film this, right?
Which doesn't sound like a lot.
But for me as someone who
already values every day
that I do work, it kind of like builds up.
So, that one day, a week
turns into like quite a lot
when we're adding like extra
secret projects on top of that.
- We have a lot coming in.
They gonna take weekends away.
- So I guess for me, especially
after Trash Taste started,
I'm trying to figure out a
good, a new work-life balance
that kind of works with
me doing everything.
And not working myself to death
or maybe I just might take
a break sometime soon.
I don't know yet, I
haven't figured it out.
- Yeah, that's the thing.
It's not about seeing
if you can take a break
or seeing like what the balance is,
because everyone's balances
I feel work really different.
Because like for me at
least, my rule of thumb is
at least three days of the week
I try and not do any YouTube stuff.
So like four days and also weekends,
- weekends
- Weekends for me as well.
So it's like two days on the weekend.
And then one to two days during the week
is just a day where I don't do anything.
It's just no work, no
YouTube work, nothing.
And then the rest of the four
days, I go balls to the walls.
And like that's all I do.
Of course it depends on my schedule.
But I feel that like,
because before, when I was
in like that really, really
like deep, deep burnout.
I wasn't going out at all.
Like I wasn't going to see anybody.
- Definitely having like a
social life is like really
important to not feeling
like you're trapped.
And I think definitely for
me, like AX and conventions
in general was such a huge,
like mini-vacation for me.
- Yeah, it's so refreshing
when you go to a convention.
- And we just didn't get that this year.
- I know.
- Which is why I think
everything's just been exasperated.
- It was awful, cause I remember
the last day AX happened.
So 2019, I distinctly
remember the week before
I was working so much that I thought like
I was just ready to like
fucking start crying
and like, come on, so I'm
just like, I can't do this.
And if that AX hadn't
happened, like at that time,
I didn't know what I would've done.
Cause I think I would
have been way too burnout.
Cause yeah, I burned myself
out so much in the anticipation
that I could enjoy this
thing and have the vacation
and luckily it was great.
I had a fucking great time.
- Yeah.
- And yeah, it's been weird now,
because we don't have any of that.
And I remember speaking to
Emily and Emily was like,
what's the last time you took a vacation.
Before the Niigata one,
and I was like, hmm,
like an actual vacation,
I think it was like two
or three years.
Never took a vacation.
It was just like maybe a weekend trip.
That was like a little getaway
for like one or two days.
But not like an actual vacation.
It actually been like two, three years.
Plus I'd actually done it
now because I'd never would.
- Yeah, cause you don't about it, right?
- No, cause conventions were my,
I mean, conventions are work.
- Technically.
- They're a hundred percent work.
- Like you still enjoyed it
and it was just a nice break
from your routine.
That's why I do my conventions.
- But I can't really call a vacation.
And it was crazy that I would
go like two, three years.
She didn't even question
if I needed a break,
like even Christmas, like,
and all the family holidays
and stuff that I would do.
I would still be doing work.
- Yeah.
- It was crazy.
- Well I think that's why I
like, I've kind of been blessed
in that aspect because I am
really good at scheduling
and getting it on top of my
schedule because I've been able
to take short vacations.
Like whether it be with
family or with friends
or just whatever, just very
frequently, like, you know,
minus all of the conventions
because to me conventions
aren't a vacation, it's just work,
but a different type of work.
- Just having like a
weekend away helps so much
to like recharge you, I think.
And as well as my videos
have been getting a lot more
ambitious as well, recently,
so I've adding on more work schedule.
- That's the power, isn't?
- Same upload schedule
but like three times
the amount of work.
- Yeah, exactly, exactly.
- I did, by the time we were recording,
like a rented boyfriend
video, first video was easy.
It was two hours of work on
my end of recording work.
Cause there's loads of other
work that went in before that.
But two hours of just
reacting to applications.
That's easy.
Second part was hard because
I had to schedule 13 people
with different time zones,
calls, one hour calls
with these people and then
plan out what I was going to do
on each call.
Because I did something
different for everyone.
One of them I had to like
get a whole Bob Ross set up
and one of them I had to get
all sculpting stuff and others.
Just different things at each
one and there's one hour each.
So just pure call times, it was 13 hours.
And then on top of that
I had to then fucking
micromanage my schedule
Which if you try and schedule times zones,
oh my fucking God.
It's not difficult, but
you feel like your brain
is going to implode trying to
juggle all these times zones
and plot them all out.
And this is just for one video.
And then, you know, back in
March I did the audio book video
which is like a month of straight work.
- Yeah, that was the most
stressed I've ever seen you.
- I thought you were
going to burnout there.
- I don't know how I did it
because I was also uploading
weekly videos in between
this behemoth of a video.
- Yeah.
- It's crazy, cause I had
to make the audio book
and make the video.
I just, I don't know how
I did not get burnout.
- That's the double edged sword, isn't it?
Is that like, the more you do YouTube
and like the moment you're like,
- I want to do better.
- The moment you decide to
venture out into that one
ambitious idea and you make
it happen and it's successful
then you start thinking,
all right, I did it once.
I can do it again, but better.
And then it just keeps getting
and then it just keeps escalating
and escalating and escalating
until you realize, oh shit,
I don't have time to make this video.
It's either going to suck
or I have to sacrifice other ideas.
- It kind of sucks when
you reached the point where
you make a banger video
and then you think, man,
how am I going to top this?
If I'm not going to top this,
what's the point of trying.
- Yeah, exactly, exactly.
- The way I see it is that like,
the videos that I put out most often
or the like the standard
videos that I hope people enjoy
and that they like buy a bit of time.
- Yeah.
- And then every now and
then I like to just hopefully
think that these are the banger videos.
The ones that like
really blow people away.
But I hope that in between
them, the videos I do put out
like keep people engaged and enjoying.
- Yeah.
I think it's kind of bitter
sweet when you do bring out
that banger video and it doesn't amazing.
And then you're like, all right
I have to upload a couple
of throwaway videos
but then throwaway videos do just as well.
(Garnt laughing)
I can literally do anything
and it'll be all right.
- By throwaway videos we mean videos
that take very little time in comparison.
- Way less time.
- The thing that you have to get around
with being a YouTuber is that
the effort you put in a video
does like hardly ever
equates the views it gets.
- Never.
- There's no correlation to that.
And you know, the people may
notice how much effort you put
in X videos, but what YouTube
cares about the metrics,
the money you make does
hardly gets affected.
- It's all idea based, right?
It's all about, do you have a better idea?
It doesn't matter how you execute it.
Do you have a better idea, if
you do, we'll pay you more.
- It's unfortunate, but I
think I've just come to accept
and I'm totally fine with
knowing that maybe my video
that I put two months of
work into won't do well.
- Yeah.
- I'm just happy that I did it.
Cause I'm like, I can at least
be like, I'm capable of this.
- It looks good on the resume.
- Yeah.
Like, I'm working on a
video right now where I was
I was a Fiverr seller for like two months
and it's all done now, but
that's two months of work.
And if that video bombs,
I was gonna be pretty sad,
- I'ma cry.
- It's gonna be pretty
fucking sad, isn't it?
Because two months, two months
of fucking work into that.
- And then afterwards you do
a video that takes an hour
to make and you'll be like,
it'll get just as many views.
- Ten times even better sometimes.
- I think that's YouTube, right?
And I think I've just come to accept now
that I'm not doing it for the views.
I'm doing it because I
want to make these videos
that I think are cool.
That's pretty much where
I've gotten to now.
- Yeah.
And I think Trash Taste's been
great because it allows me
to just even more further
lean that mindset of,
I don't really care
cause we have Trash Taste
and Trash Taste gets more
views than most of my videos.
And it's just me chatting shit for hours.
So I gotta not give a
shit about the views.
- Yeah.
- I've definitely started to
care less on my main channel.
- Trash Taste is...
- Care less about the views actually.
- No, no.
- I don't give a fuck about my channel.
- Trash Taste has really
been like bittersweet
just to see like how much
effort we put into our videos
on our own channels.
Then we come in and
chat shit for two hours
and we're like a million views
for like two hours just chatting.
And I'm just like, what am I doing right?
And what am I doing wrong?
- It's like, hold on a million views.
And there's only three cuts in
the video, what's happening.
- It's nice though because
it feels that like obviously
there's, we're doing something right here.
You guys must enjoy it.
I don't know.
I think our dynamic must
be working, I guess.
I don't know.
I mean, I'm very glad
that it's doing well.
- But that's the thing, right?
Is that because of Trash
Taste, because this is quite
different to what I do and what we all do
in our own channels.
It's kind of incentivized
me more to explore different
things on my main channel.
Like, I recently brought out
a video where I kind of go
personal into like my whole
thing about being half-Japanese.
- That was a really good video.
And I was really scared to upload that.
Because it's got nothing to do with anime
and it's just my life story basically.
And I'm like, I really
don't want this to look
like another sob story.
Like a woe is me type of story,
but people really enjoyed it.
I asked Mudan as well to like
do a little bit different
on the editing side of things
and everything turned out amazing.
So when I saw that video
do well, I was like, okay,
maybe I can, even though
I'm called the Anime Man,
maybe not every video
has to be about anime.
Maybe I can go back to my Let's Play days
and just do whatever the fuck I want.
- A lot might not know about
voice acting so, it's fine.
- Yeah, I know.
But at least you also just VA, right?
Like you don't have CDawg voice actor.
- That's true.
- Not all my videos are
about the United Kingdom.
(Connor and Joey laughing)
So, it's all good, man.
It's all good.
- Why did you stop talking about Arizona?
Where did the Arizona go?
- Why not then review
Virginia for the moment
and see what's up with that.
- Yeah, I dunno.
It's just, I dunno, cause with me, right.
At least with you guys,
because your names are a
lot more general, right?
You're not bound to a certain topic.
Not like I am.
- Have you ever thought
about changing your name?
- I have, in a sense, yes.
Actually a number of
times I thought about it.
Like, when I was still doing Let's Plays.
I thought about changing it,
just because first of all,
half of the games I
play aren't even anime.
Second of all, I'm uploading
like five Lets Plays in a week
and tWo anime videos in a week.
So I thought, is there really a point
to call myself the Anime Man?
But at that point, now the
Anime Man is just a brand.
- Yeah, true.
- People know me, not as
Joey, but as the Anime Man.
So it's really hard to just
suddenly change the name.
Because I've seen instances of YouTubers
who are already established in a name,
who decide on a whim to
change their user name
to something, because it
doesn't fit their current image
and it's never worked out.
- Yeah, I know, I know.
One channel, I think it's worked out
there was a channel called, I
guess he goes by Lemmino now,
have you seen his videos?
- Oh yeah.
He used to be a top 10 channel.
- Top 10, he's still a top 10.
- My God, Lemmino.
Like, now he basically just
does Netflix documentaries.
That's kind of like the
level of YouTube content
that he puts out.
- Really, really good stuff.
He used to be called Top Tens.
And obviously he's not doing top 10's now.
I think he might do
them, every now and then.
I don't think he does though.
Yeah, he changed his name.
And I remember being weirded out at first.
I was like what? why?
But now you don't give a shit
- Yeah, but that's the thing, right?
I feel that is just a
really small handful.
- True.
- Most of the time
you're just like, oh God,
why did the name change?
- You'll basically be
resetting all the SEO's
- Why are they making
completely different content?
I didn't sign up for this shit.
- I mean, like, respect to
anyone who has the balls
to do that because I
wouldn't be able to get away
from like, my brand that I've built up
over this entire time.
- Like, that's like
if, for example, right.
- Like you took away VA in your name.
And you just turn it to CDawg.
- I don't think it would change anything.
- I dunno, man.
- I think it's more like if
you just change your name
to like Connor.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, true, true, true.
- That's the reason why,
like, for me, for example,
I want to like say on Trash Taste, right?
I just want to be established as Joey.
Not as the Anime Man,
because I feel that's a
completely different side of me.
- Yeah.
You've gotten the clips on you now? right?
Cause we had a discussion when
we were making the channel.
We were like, so in the clip.
So we calling us the Anime Man.
And did X, X thing or like Joey.
I think I was at the
mindset of like, okay, well.
It's a podcast and it's very
personal and we're probably
gonna be talking about personal things.
I think it should be Connor,
Joey, Garnt et cetera.
- Yeah, and not to say
that we don't mind you guys
calling us by our usernames.
But I think the end game for Trash Taste
at least in my mind is that
I don't want to be known
as The Anime Man, Gigguk and CDawg.
I wanted us to be known
as Joey, Garnt and Connor of Trash Taste.
- The boys.
- The boys, right?
- Yeah.
- I remember.
I just, I wanted to be able to like,
cause I have all these cool stories
that are fucking useless to me.
What am I going to do?
When am I ever going to get
mileage out of the story?
- When am I going to monetize my stories?
- Let's just commoditize it.
- Let's just commoditize
my entire fucking life.
- Dude, I love telling the chest story.
Cause that's such a fucking cool story.
I never get any use out of that.
And also people will just like, I dunno.
It's like adding layers to me,
I love it when I get to learn
more about a creator and
like that personal side
I actually like, I like,
I think that, I dunno.
I just also, I'm just gonna
say I love fucking talking.
I love talking.
I just won't shut the fuck up.
- I mean, I would argue
we wouldn't have a podcast
if we didn't like talking.
- That's true.
- That's why I can stream just
chatting for like four hours.
Cause I'm a fucking psychopath I guess,
I just won't shut up.
- I have too many stories to hold.
- I just want to keep
fucking chatting shit.
I don't know, I love talking
and it's great being able to.
I love talking about YouTube as well.
- Because you never get
the opportunity to do it.
- You never, because all of
our friends, all of our family,
they don't know what the fuck we do.
- Yeah, and then I could
talk about it with you guys
but I pretty dominate every
single conversation we have
off the podcast.
You know what I mean?
So it's nice to just talk about it here.
And then we can just chat shit.
Like poopy poopoo, stinky,
in private, you know.
- We're sorry for anyone
who goes into this podcast
thinking it was going to be
like an anime exclusive podcast.
- Because I know on.
- I think you two are worried about that.
- And I was like, no, dude,
I want us to be like chatting shit.
- No, no, no, I want it
to be like, eventually,
we start off as an Anime podcast.
- And we eventually grow out.
- And then we can eventually
maybe start tensioning out.
But not right from the get-go
first episode, we were like,
- I'm glad, I'm glad.
- Japan.
- Yeah, let's talk about Japan.
Yeah, but we're really glad
that you guys have like,
kind of stuck around and just
enjoyed us chatting shit.
Like arguably more so than
us chatting about anime.
- I wonder, I mean, going
back to the previous topic,
is it like, cause you hear a lot of advice
that YouTubers give to people.
I feel a lot of it's pretty shit.
Let's be honest.
A lot of it's pretty funny fucking
- Like how so?
I mean, don't give examples necessarily,
but like, how are they shit?
- There's generic phrases
that YouTubers say,
and we, let's be honest.
We say it cause it's fucking easy.
Like...
- You mean what I'm going to
call like the convention panel.
- Garnt, give me the most stereotypical.
And I'll say if these are the shit ones,
give me stereotypical answers on advice
when someone asks you
how to be a YouTuber.
- Just be yourself.
(Garnt laughs)
- That is fucking terrible advice.
- Shake my head.
- Do you know how many people
I know who are insufferable.
(laughing)
I have so many mates where I'm like,
listen you're a fantastic mate.
But if you act like this on camera,
no one's going to want to watch.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
You have a lot of mates.
You're like, you just kind
of come off as a dick.
- Let's say, because for
me now I used to say,
just be yourself and
just have fun with it.
Have fun with it.
You know?
But nowadays I just make it a meme because
I get also many times.
Someone's like, how do you
start becoming a YouTuber?
I just say, hit the upload button.
- Are we actually going
to break this down?
- Should we give advice?
I think why not? cause people want to know
fucking YouTube advice
and we may as well like,
actually give good advice.
- Okay, how to become
a successful YouTuber
from Trash Taste.
I feel like we say generic
advice because there's like,
I feel like the generic
advice that we give
is like the core of like...
- It is fucking useless to most people.
- It is useless because
there's only so much
you can say like a half hour panel
- It's one of those
things where it's like,
you know, in the show when
the old man gives advice
and you're like, that's fucking dumb.
And then 10 years later
when he actually does it
you're like, fuck, he was right.
That's pretty much the advice.
Like, cause you're like
it's completely useless
to anyone starting out.
Cause that doesn't mean anything
when you've been doing it for this long.
Yeah, it is the core, like you said.
- Yeah.
- But the be yourself thing is like,
I think that's the biggest like,
- Cop out.
It is a bit of a cop out.
- Because you don't, you're not,
yourself as a normal person,
you're not a presenter.
No one normally is a presenter
or a personality who's
made for like cameras.
You have to, you have to
get that, and you do it
by forcing yourself to act
maybe a little bit more
exaggerated than you normally do.
And then over time, maybe
you get way more comfortable
and it does become your
kind of like default.
Right?
- I dunno, because like,
be yourself to me is like
I guess less accurate than just,
don't try to be someone you're not.
- That's true.
Don't change your personality.
- If you are going to play a character,
play a character that is
based on your own self.
- True.
- Which is I feel like, well,
like a lot of us do online anyway.
You know what I mean?
It's just like an exaggerated
perfected version of ourselves.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's what I say.
I say like, imagine you on your best day
and that is you on every single
one of these YouTube videos.
That's what should it be?
You know, whether or not
that should be right?
Like, should you be sad on
camera and stuff like that?
It's like, not really about that.
It's, think of every single
best personality trait you have
and show that, make that come through.
- Yeah.
- And so that does require
a little bit of, you know,
a bit of fuckery, going
home with your personality.
You do have to change it a little bit.
But I found as well that
it made me a better person
in general that like I, the
things that people liked
about me became more prominent
in my general personality.
So it wasn't more so that
I was faking it more so
that the real me kind of changed
into a more confident version of myself.
And I, you know, you should pass a way
of really making you see your flaws.
- Oh yeah.
- It's a fine balance as
well, because I feel that
it's not about like, faking
a personality, right?
Because if you...
- It's exaggerated.
- But if you exaggerate it too much
that's when people are like,
then you become access to doubt
- Then you become that
psychopathic vlogger.
- Yeah, then you become
that psychopathic vlogger
who is like the most angel image online.
But then when you meet them in person
they're an absolute cunt.
- Yeah.
- It's like, sometimes in conventions,
people come up to me like, wow,
you're a lot more calm
than in your videos.
And it's like, well,
yeah, because, oh, yeah.
- Did you get that?
- I mean, I am like, if I'm
fucking crazy in my videos,
or doing something stupid.
Like, I genuinely am like that
but you can't do that all the time.
- Yeah.
- Otherwise you're a psychopath.
- You're either a psychopath or Guy Fieri.
- You know, in real life
it's fucking annoying.
You're in a friend group
and someone wants to be
the center of attention all the time.
Like, it's not natural to want the center
of attention all the time.
Like, it's totally okay to be
in a friend group and be like,
I'm just not going to say
anything for five minutes
and I'll wait for my time to join in.
- Yeah, exactly.
- And if you don't join
in at all, that's fine.
- Yeah man, that's what I thought.
- You can just be there.
- Yeah, there's plenty
of YouTubers I've met
where, you know, you'll like,
oh, you're totally different.
- Oh yeah.
- You're not even close.
- Not gonna say any
names, obviously, but...
- I don't wanna get in trouble.
- we've had our fair share.
- This is the gospel we have
behind the scenes, unfortunately.
- Yeah, if the cameras weren't on
we'd totally be saying names.
Yeah, that person sucks.
- It's because you wouldn't...
Okay, you see drama on YouTube
behind the scenes sometimes.
And you're like, wow, everyone is drama.
No one knows about it.
That's kind of crazy.
So yeah, every, YouTuber you
watch probably has some drama.
- Yeah, it's just about whether they...
- Everyone has dirt on someone else.
- That's just about whether
they choose to monetize it.
(Garnt laughing)
- That's so true, that's so true
- But everyone has shit with other people.
It's very natural.
- I've had issues before, but
I've always done it in private
and I've always swamped in private.
You know what I mean?
- Same.
- If someone's crossed
the line I've told them.
- Yeah, I guess going back
to like general advice
on how to be a successful YouTuber.
I think one thing that's
not really mentioned a lot
is just know who your audience is.
Like, don't try to appeal to everyone.
You know what I mean?
- You can't please everyone.
- You're gonna be disliked
by a lot of people.
- Yeah, you're gonna be
disliked by a lot of people,
just accept that.
I feel like one thing that
not many people think about,
especially like even us, when we started,
we didn't really think about it.
We didn't really think, oh, I
want to be this kind of person
or aim for this kind of audience
but it's something you kind of grow into.
And now all three of us
have very different brands
in terms of like what
our content is about.
And it's something we grow into.
But you like anyone,
anyone who's trying to
be a YouTuber has a harder
time getting into that
because you have way more competition.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Right?
Because I know that if I
were just starting YouTube
out today, I would be totally different.
Like my content would be totally different
than what I'm doing now.
And that's because I exist, right?
So if I exist, then you
can't do the same thing,
you can't exist in the
same space that I do.
And so one thing that you've got to find
is like a unique way to
make yourself memorable.
And sometimes that might just be
how you approach your content.
Sometimes that may be your personality.
But a lot of the successful
YouTubers that are rising up
quickly have found a way
to make their own niche.
Even if it's like this
very saturated market.
Like I think the person
who like sticks out to me,
the most recent that I can
think of was like Nikki Jakey
and how fast he rose.
And that's because his content
and the way he delivered it
was just so unique compared
to every other gaming content
out there, even though gaming
was such a saturated market.
- Gaming outside of YouTube is everywhere.
- And I would say like,
that's one extreme.
You don't have to go
like, as unique as him,
but even like a lot of other
people who are rising up
have found a way to make
their own voice unique
or make their presentation
unique or something
that is memorable about them.
If that makes sense.
- And it's funny as well,
because a lot of those types
of YouTubers tend to be the most humble.
- Yeah.
- Because like I remember in a
Nike Jakey video he once said
like, yeah, because I'm just
John Tron on an exercise ball.
So he said, that's what he called himself.
He's like, I'm John Tron
on an exercise ball.
And I'm like, you shouldn't
sell yourself that short
because he's completely different.
He's made up his own thing.
And I feel, as you said,
that's, that's the thing, right?
It's like, there's nothing
wrong with getting inspired
by an already existing
YouTuber, being like,
I like that aspect of this YouTuber.
So I'm going to take
that into my own thing.
But there's a difference
between getting inspired
by PewDiePie and then
trying to be PewDiePie 2.0.
- I think when I started
YouTube, I think like,
I definitely loved dance videos,
but I just knew that like,
that's just doesn't work with me.
- Yeah.
- As much as I'd love
to make a Gigguk video.
I just can't, that's
not, I can't pull it off.
- It's a Gigguk video
because it's a Gigguk video.
- I think you learn, a good
YouTuber will learn very quickly
what tools they're working with.
And you can figure out what you
can kind of get out of that.
It's difficult though,
because I think again,
like you've said, like a lot
of people with like specialties
are coming up now.
So if you want to join
something, like gaming
you need a fucking good skill to separate.
- Yeah, exactly.
- So think like, if you're making a video,
like is it just another
carbon copy of someone else's
or I always told myself, like, let's say
even though we're in
different genres, right?
Let's say Markiplier
uploads a video, right.
At the same time I upload a video.
What reason does someone have
to watch my video over his?
Because you know, that's, I
mean, this is the problem.
It's only X amount of time in the day
and you need the eyeballs on you.
So you need to make your videos
as good as the best people
on YouTube, otherwise
people aren't gonna watch.
- Yeah.
- Like some people will and,
and they'll be very grateful
because you're doing a very niche thing.
But in general, you need
to make your content
like as good as other people around you.
It doesn't matter how
big or small you are.
This is the fundamental.
- Yeah, because everybody
starts off small.
- Everyone starts off small.
The problem is, is that
the YouTube algorithm
doesn't give a fuck at your side.
- I mean, I'd say that.
I obviously agree.
You should make your
content as good as possible.
I just don't think.
Especially as a small growing
YouTuber, making your content
as good as like some
of the bigger YouTubers
- You're not going to, but
you should have that mindset.
- You should eventually.
But what I'm saying is like,
if you're starting our YouTube
some of the charm, is just
discovering this YouTuber
who just like, is like
a diamond in the rough.
You shouldn't, like the
quality of your videos.
You shouldn't need to
think that you need to make
like a John Tron fucking quality
video of right off the bat.
Because like, I feel like you
should, getting into YouTube,
you should understand what
YouTube is at it's core.
- Yeah, cause I think I
watched, like I still do.
I watch like 40 hours
plus of YouTube a week
and been doing that for like years
- And YouTube at its core
isn't a video hosting platform.
YouTube at a core is a
friendship simulator.
- Oh.
- And I mean, that's, that's, it is.
- I really want to be friends
with report of the week man.
I love that man seriously.
- Because, the thing is, a
lot of the most successful
YouTubers, you know what
their personality is like
and a lot of the reason
why I started watching
like YouTubers big or small is
because I like a certain part
of their personality.
And there was some like, even
if there was someone I hated
there was part of their personality
or part of their content
that I couldn't stop watching
it, what drew me to it.
- Right.
- And I feel like a lot of
the successful YouTubers
have been able to kind of
like convey their personality
into their content in
some way, that goes back
to like being like memorable
and stuff like that.
But you know, it plays into
like parasocial relationships
and all that, which is a
totally fucking different topic.
But if you're talking about
success, like it's basically you
the more you can become
successful successful quickly
by just having people who
relate to you as a person.
- That's true.
- And that goes into,
you can't please everyone
because your personality is not
going to appeal to everyone.
But having your own,
putting yourself out there.
And if people like you, or if people
find part of you interesting
and you can convey that,
then you will grow as a YouTuber.
- It's true
I think, unfortunately
everyone can't be like,
ultra mega charming right off the bat.
Like, I mean like report of the week.
I love that guy's, I love him.
And that kind of personality
doesn't come along often.
It's just pure, charming
and like innocence.
- Yeah.
- But you know, what if you
have like just a normal,
medium, boring personality.
Like, I feel like I probably
had like a boring aspect.
- All of our first
videos were just like...
- Yeah, and just developing that
along your, finding your
niche like you said.
Like going into it.
Like knowing your audience,
like these are all Important things.
- Like, I was someone who was
like this, awkward social kid.
- Same, same.
- And especially like, as a YouTuber
I still don't feel like
I've changed a lot.
I just know that, hey, like
if I'm going to be like,
when I realized, hey, if I'm going
to be a fucking degenerate,
let's just like notch.
Let's just go all out.
I don't fucking give a shit anymore.
And it's just taking part of yourselves
and just like going full throttle with it.
I dunno, I dunno because I knew it.
- I agree.
- I knew like that's just
gonna make you stand out.
You know what I mean?
Like now I'm not ashamed
of being a degenerate
and I'm fucking glad that I
took that change in my content,
because like, it just
made me less embarrassed
about being who I was originally.
And like, instead of being a quiet kid,
I could just talk about all the shit
I was like, thinking about.
- Anime titties.
- Anime titties, let's go baby.
- So bottom line, how to
be a successful YouTuber,
be yourself (Garnt
laughs) just be yourself.
- I guess that's, yeah.
- That's kind of like
what I'm talking about.
- That's what it all goes back to.
- Because it's the core, right?
It's the fucking core
that I'm talking about.
Well, I can't normally,
I can't say this kind
of answer in a fucking panel.
- Oh yeah, no.
You're just fucking
bore everyone to death.
But you know, there's and
I also think it's important
to just upload, like, just do it.
- Consistency.
- I have so many friends who are like,
I'm working on something
big, like it's big, bro.
I'm sure you all have this friend.
Who's like, Oh, I've
got shit in the works.
Yeah, and then it's like two years later.
Oh, it's, it's coming.
- Yeah, it's coming.
- It's coming.
- Then they upload it.
And then they're like, that's
it, I'm famous, I'm done.
And then they realize
they have to do it again.
- Yeah, the amount of
channels I've seen that have
more update videos than actual content
on their channel is staggering.
- And it's that thing right.
Where I think everyone who
watches YouTube, idolizes
that YouTuber who uploads
once every three months.
And it's a legendary, right.
But in reality, there's
only a very small room
for channels like that.
There's only a select few who can do that.
And in reality, most of us
have to just keep fucking uploading.
That's just how it is.
Because a lot of us aren't
capable of putting in
that amount of work into a video.
Like I love , what's his name?
Frederik Knudsen.
What is his name?
- Down the rabbit hole.
- Down the rabbit hole, love his videos.
I don't mind how long it takes him.
Cause that that man must put in.
I don't want even want to
know how much work he puts in.
I love that wings of redemption.
- It's like a two and
half hour long video.
- Yeah, I've watched it like
four times and I love it.
- In the same sense, like the
right opinion, for example.
- Yeah, I've watched this for...
- Fucking four hours.
- When I was sick I watched
this four hour video
in one sitting of his
Nick Carter avocado video.
And I thought I was losing
my damn mind watching this.
But you know, again, it's a very,
everyone wants to be that channel, right?
The really well-respected
channel that does that.
But unfortunately I think as a YouTuber
you'll know very quickly on
if you can do that or not,
if that's your kind of thing,
some people can do that.
A lot of people just
just got to accept that you're going to be
that dude who makes one
video every two days.
Like, and there's nothing wrong with that.
Like just embrace it.
- There's a space for that on YouTube.
- Yeah, there's a space for everything.
If you've got to make slime videos, don't.
- I for one love the slime videos,
- Oh, fuck.
- to be honest with you.
When I discovered that like a week ago
I was like, okay, kind of
like, I'm not gonna lie.
- Do you know what the biggest pitfall,
I think a lot of YouTubers fall down?
Is that when they get one
successful video series
they're like make 10 of that.
Make 10 of that,
- Do it again.
- And I think...
- You mean every top 10 channel?
- Oh my God, you meet people.
And they make, they just make repeats
and repeats of the same video.
And you've got to realize like,
if that's the only thing
that's pulling people in
you haven't made any other foundation
to keep people engaged.
- Yeah, you've got to be patient.
- When that stops, eventually
we're gonna get bored
of doing it.
You kind of got not really anything else.
That's why like...
- You're going to burn out, eventually,
like we talked about.
Putting a foundation is actually
really, really important
and something that most
people don't think about
because most people would just want to get
as successful as they can.
- More views, more views, more views
And it's like, I've been
doing the cosplay series
and yeah, I've, I've
done a fuck ton of those
but I do one of them about
every two, three months.
So they're really well spaced
out and it's really important
to just make sure you're diversifying it
so that it's not like a business meeting.
Make sure the synergy of your
uploads are diverse enough
to get to cooperation.
- I mean, that's the exact problem I had
with the Antony standby, right?
Like I haven't done one
in, like seven months
eight months or something.
And people to this day
ask me, when's the next?
- When you bring it out.
People are gonna be like, hell, yeah.
- When I do it, eventually,
maybe, it's going to be great.
But the reason why I stopped making those
for the longest time is because
that's exactly what happened.
It was really successful the first time.
And I was like, I'll do it every week
just do it over and over and over again
I made like 60 anime samples, right?
- Yeah.
- And now at this point, I'm like,
I want to do something else with it.
I just don't want to like
upload another Q and A again,
because that's essentially what it is.
It's just a fucking Q and A.
- I also just want to
make sure people know
that at the end of the
day, we're fucking dudes
who talk shit in front of the
camera, it's not a big deal.
Like why do people get like,
people with 10,000 subs stacking egos?
And I'm like, bro, my job is
to literally me being a clown
I like, do not think you're hot shit ever.
- I don't know why people
do that either though.
- You talk about Japanese car
torrents, dude, that's sad.
(laughing)
I'm like dude, come on,
fucking know your place, Jesus Christ.
- It's like, it blows my mind or you see
like some of these
channels, like you see like,
do you see like reaction channels?
And they're like, I'm
kind of a big deal now.
Bro.
- Bro, like chill, like chill.
I see the shit you're posting on Twitter.
I'm just like, bro, just stop man.
- The audacity of this man is just insane.
- There are like a few
channels who could be complete
assholes and I'd be like,
I'm still gonna watch dude.
You're fucking God to your content.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You deserve a good dig sucking.
But most of us are shitty YouTubers,
who don't make anything.
So don't get an ego.
We don't do anything impressive.
Yeah, I think having
that Attitude towards it,
like give it, I H one
of my videos of my baby
and I cashed so much about it,
but I never ever think
I'm like anything special.
- Yeah.
- I think that goes a
long way in making you
a down to earth person in personality.
- Being humble goes a very, very long way.
And, that's what it is, as
Garnt said before, right?
Like YouTube is just a
friendship simulator.
And if you want to get those friendships,
being humble is probably
the best personality trait
you can have on YouTube.
- Oh dude, dude.
I've made some of the best
friends in my life from YouTube,
you guys, right?
- Yeah, exactly.
Here we are now, the boys.
- The boys wouldn't have come together
if one of us was a dick
- Everyone I've met,
obviously, including you guys
it's just like you meet
and you just have this
like you can totally
tell that they just don't
see themselves as anything special.
- No.
- I mean, I feel like very lucky
to be in the place that I am now.
I wake up and I'm like, man,
I'm fucking lucky to be here.
- Dude, I'm a smash of Colombini sandwich
and get back to work.
This is amazing.
Like I'm in fucking Japan.
- Yeah. I know.
Meanwhile like people
with like a hundred K subs
and just like the massive ego is like,
where's my caviar in the morning.
- I've seen some abhorrent behavior
from people who just think
that they're hot shit.
- Yeah.
And then this isn't
just limited to YouTube,
but like Instagrammers.
- Oh, Instagram is the worst.
- My God, like just chill.
Don't don't be an asshole.
That's the second thing.
- You want to be successful
YouTuber, don't be a dick.
- But also I think thinking
about the future as well
and just planning ahead
I think is also important
because for like, when
you hear about YouTube
success stories, everyone
always just sees,
oh man, they're growing
so fucking quickly, right?
I want that.
I want to grow.
I want to grow quickly.
But what they don't see
a lot of the times is how
fucking long a lot of these
YouTubers worked before that.
Cause you always see that one
YouTuber who rises up quickly
like Mr. Beast, for example.
Mr. Beast was like, I
think it was last year
or two years ago.
He was like the hottest shit
on YouTube in terms of...
- He still kinda is.
- I mean, he's still here.
He's approaching like 50 mil or something.
He's like one of the biggest
creators on this platform.
But what a lot of people don't talk about
is just how many times he had failed
and how many different kinds
of content that he did.
And he's like, if you
want to be a YouTuber
you're going to put in the grind
and it is going to be a grind
and not a lot of YouTubers
talk about the grinds they put into
before they were like successful.
Cause everyone always sees
that massive fucking year that they had.
But like, I remember
being a small YouTuber
and working like, I've been
on YouTube for 13 years.
Most of that 13 years was
being a, fucking nobody.
You know what I mean?
- I have a question.
How many years did you work
on your YouTube channel
before you saw a penny?
- Seven, eight years.
- Jesus Christ.
- Okay, do you ever get those
comments where people like,
dude YouTubers make too much money?
And then I always just tell them, dude,
work for seven years for nothing.
And then see if you, like, if you want.
Tell me you want to work for
seven years at the chance
of being successful
and getting some money.
And it's also a system that
allows some amazing things.
The reason why some people
make, you know, like,
I'm never going to make nearly
as much money as someone
like Logan or Jake Paul makes.
But that system is also in place
so that one animator who
makes one video a month
can just make enough to get by.
Because if Logan Paul and Jake
Paul didn't make that much
then the animator down there
couldn't make that much.
You know what I mean?
And it's, yeah.
Some of these YouTubers have
way too much fucking money.
- Oh yeah.
- But it's a system that
you only see the success
and you never, like you said,
you never see the hard work.
Like you never see the 40 hours a week
I was putting in while
trying to get a degree.
- Yeah, when we say rise and grind
we mean that half as a joke,
like we genuinely mean that.
- I mean, we talked
about how we try to have
a less hands on approach now.
Like, some of us to varying degrees.
- Like any business, you grow
and you delegate the job.
- Like, I don't think there
is literally a YouTuber
I know that hasn't gone through a period
where all they did was do
YouTube, from morning to night
from like waking up to night.
Like there was a year I'm
sure for all three of us
where this was all we did.
And we put in that fucking grind
and the hard part was learning
once we were successful
how to get out of this grind
because it's like unsustainable.
But you gotta be prepared
to put the work in there
because it is going to be
really, really hard fucking work
because you got to compete with everyone.
And every YouTuber I know
has gone through a period
where they've just wanted
to fucking kill themselves
for how much work they've done.
But that's, that's just the landscape.
Cause that's how much
people want to succeed.
And if you're not prepared
to do that for like a year,
at least, because some
people did in a month.
Like minimum, you got
to do this for a year.
It doesn't matter what kind
of life situation you're in.
Whether you're in like fucking uni,
like who you're working, you've got a job
YouTube doesn't care, YouTube
doesn't wait for that shit.
- It's unfortunate because,
you know, obviously,
likely the more older you get,
the more responsibilities you have,
which means less time for YouTube.
And it just, it sucks because
life isn't fucking fair.
And you know, we're really
lucky that we all started
at like a perfect time,
which is in university
where we could afford
to throw everything else
out the window.
And I feel bad, cause
sometimes you get emails
from people who are like,
working fathers and you're like,
hey, I really need to do X and X.
And I'm like, fuck dude.
Like, I mean, it's kinda
hard cause you really have
to put in way more time
than you could ever put in
in your situation.
It sucks because it's not fair.
- Because like for me, when people ask me,
what do I have to do to
like make YouTube my job?
The first thing I asked
them no matter how many
like sub counts they have,
if they were thinking
about making this a job,
I'm like are you prepared
to take a year out of your life?
- To make it work.
- To make it work, at least
a year out of your life.
If you're prepared to take
a year out of your life
to make this work then it's
something I think is feasible
with the right work ethic.
Because it's not just about work.
It's not just about, cause with YouTube
you'd not only have to work hard,
you have to work smart as
well too, to stand out.
- And that's not even a guarantee, right?
That that one year is
like you have a chance
of becoming successful.
- If we're throwing
pure numbers into this,
into the algorithm, I
feel like if you have
over 100,000 subscribers,
you can make this into a job.
- Yeah, you probably could.
Maybe not right at that
point, but you can easily get.
- With a good amount of views.
With a healthy amount of views.
- With a healthy amount of views,
like if you've just like, obviously,
just reached a hundred
thousand and you have like,
- Don't quit your job.
- I'm not saying you can quit your job
but you do have a chance
to make this a job
if you play your cards right.
But like I said, are you
prepared to take a year
off your life, maybe?
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- That's kinda like the crossroads.
I've seen a lot of people at
- And there's also,
you might see a channel
and they might've gotten
like a big burst of numbers
but there's maybe something
going on in the channel
that's quite unhealthy.
Like, you'd see, like if that
channel is like low views,
low views, low views, low
views, and one big view.
And that's consistently
what they're getting,
it's normally a bad sign.
- Yeah.
- We can just see a
channel and we can know
if it's going to be like successful.
- Because most of the time, if
you reach a hundred thousand
you have some kind of foundation.
- You've been doing something right.
- You've got a foundation
and it's, this is like,
unless you've just had one bang of video
and then you've just
reached under a thousand.
But like most, like I'm throwing this out.
But like most of the cases I know.
where someone reaches a
hundred thousand, I knew
that they could turn into a job.
It was something that
you won't be living well,
when you when you start off, like,
- None of us did.
- none of us were.
- I was worrying about being
kicked out of my house.
- Yeah.
- So that was fun.
- But if you understand
enough about how to monetize
your work and the internet,
like fucking artists,
please please learn how
to monetize your work.
There's so many talented people out there
where they're not making a single penny
because they don't know how
to market their skillsets.
Like if you just do a bit of research
about how to market yourself
and how to monetize your
platform, you can make this a job.
- I truly do think
anyone can be a YouTuber.
Like it's not,
- I do as well.
- I think it just takes
different amounts of time
for different people.
- Yeah.
- But I think anyone can do it.
- Some people it just clicks,
for some people you're really
have to grind it out.
- At the end of the day, you know?
And even if you're working
father with 10 kids
I'm sure there is a chance of some path
that you could make it work.
- You just got to figure it out.
- It's hard, man.
I mean there's no foolproof
way to make it happen.
- We're not saying it's easy.
There's no foolproof way,
but there is, I guess ways
that you can increase your chances.
There's a lot of ways.
- We can definitely go way more in-depth
into this in future podcasts.
- I could chat for like four
hours of this shit, but...
- Yeah, yeah.
- So we'll probably leave
us for another episode,
but in the meantime, guys.
Thank you to all the Patreons.
First of all, as you
can see on the screen.
- Beautiful motherfuckers on the screen.
I love this guy and this guys.
- They're all amazing people.
And if you like to be...
- This guy could be a successful YouTuber.
That guy could be successful YouTuber.
- What if you all like pointing to like
an already successful YouTuber.
- CDawgVA, I'm not successful yet.
- So fun dude.
But yeah, if you'd like
to join in on the patreon
and help us support the
show then go to patreon.com.
- We haven't drank the wine.
- No, we will, don't worry.
But yeah, also follow us on
the subreddit and Twitter
post your memes, all that good shit.
And also,
- Trash Taste shirts babe.
- Check out our shirts if you
want to spread the degeneracy
and the Trash fucking tickets
- Okay and this pre-orders
will only be around
for two weeks, I believe,
until October 24th.
So again, go to bakuretsu.co/trashtaste
link's in the description.
If you'd like to pre-order these,
because once these are
gone, these are gone.
So get in on that shit quickly, guys.
- Dude, I know YouTube
is live all the time
and they say like, dude, it feels good.
And then it's like fucking
sandpaper, but this is actually,
this is so fucking cool.
- We know the guy who made this
and we can guarantee
this shit feels clean.
- This is actually the
sample that we asked him
to send to us before we were like,
okay, we want to promote it.
- We wanna know before we promote it
- We've tested this with our own skin.
We can confirm it's great.
Yeah so, yeah guys, thanks
again for joining in
on another episode of Trash Taste.
I've been simp boy number
one with simp boy number two
and three.
- Yeah, simp boy three.
- I've been super simp,
- Super simp.
- Is there a YouTuber here
that you're simping on
- I'm about to go super simp.
- I'm leaving, bye.
- Me when I don't need to beat you.
I'll see you guys later.
Bye.
(upbeat music)